so it's December and I started thinking
to myself what kind of videos can I do
this month something wholesome nice and
christmas-related
then the more I thought about it I'm
doing a lot of Christmas videos this one
as I do every month and for whatever
reason I started thinking about the
Disney films you know the ones that we
all the more I was thinking about it
there wholesome all the time they don't
wait one month a year to shine all the
magic and goodness of humanity on us
they have to be whimsical all year round
and that can't be easy
so I decided screw it I'm just gonna
review all the Disney films that is to
say all the animated 2d Disney films
with some exceptions why because I love
Disney and so do you oh you may act like
you don't like Disney you may talk about
how it's an evil corporate monster that
only gets stronger and stronger the
longer we live but the funny thing is
you don't have a choice you can bombard
us with all the genius monstrous things
that Disney has done in the past
you can argue debatable messages you can
argue debatable ethics you can even
argue debatable stereotypes but it
doesn't matter
Disney has always been there for most of
us it's the first thing we're introduced
to and that's the genius of Disney
putting all the time and all their
effort not in something adult but in
something for children and once
something has your childhood by the
balls it's never gonna leave you it's
there forever
Disney has practically become family to
us it's fairy tales it's magic it's
everything that we enjoyed and thought
was possible when we were younger and as
we for older there's all of other things
to enjoy the artistry the creativity the
imagination there's literally no other
word for it but Disney it's an artistic
cultural phenomenon that will never ever
leave now I'm just gonna state upfront
that I am directly ripping off
cinemassacre x' monster bands
we're james rolfe reviews a new monster
movie every day of october i think it's
a cool idea and i want to do it what
something I really enjoyed the
hand-drawn animated Disney movies the
only downside is there's only so many
days in December and there's just a
friggin boat load of beets boobies so
I'm probably gonna do about three a day
and once or twice that may skip over but
I'll do my best to comment on as many as
possible and keep in mind this is just
my own personal pick if you like or hate
any of these films there's nothing wrong
with them I'm just putting out though
what I think of some of the most beloved
classics of all time so sit back and
enjoy the month of what I like to call
Disney 7
let's start off with the very first
animated film ever made Snow White and
the Seven Dwarves we often associate the
Disney formula with a princess and a big
castle in some sort of far-off fairy
tale and even though not all the films
are like that in fact probably not even
the majority that's the one kids seem to
like the most and it started at the very
beginning Disney knew then that the more
timeless you can make something the
longer it'll be around so logically it
makes sense to start off with a fairy
tale and as the first film goes it's
pretty damn impressive I mean okay it's
not entirely timeless I mean the designs
are kind of 40s some of the characters
aren't as developed as children's films
are today it's Snow White singing voices
very bitty bitch to describe the story
is almost silly we all know it an evil
queen wants to be the quote-unquote
fairest of them all but finds out that
there's only one young woman in her way
the princess Snow White so she sends a
hunter out to kill her but the hunter is
just so blown away by how hot she is he
can't do it so he tells her to run away
and she comes across a cottage filled
with Seven Dwarves which for me as a kid
always raised a lot of questions are the
dwarves related are they brothers did
they all just meet at random if so is
there a place where dwarves just usually
meet well I'm overanalyzing the Queen
finds out that Snow White is still alive
and puts on a disguise to try and kill
her kind of Dreams if you wouldn't just
send a henchman or somebody else to do
it they definitely have just the one but
again over analyzing the film is about
as basic children's movie as you can get
is very bright it's very colorful but it
doesn't try to insult the audience
intelligence either as Disney Princesses
go Snow White is probably one of the
weaker ones as she is sort of just bland
and general and ice but on the upside
she is generally nice there's nothing
really wrong with her she's just not
particularly interesting to be fair
though she's a lot more engaging than
the prince who only gets about three
lines and most of them are just some the
dwarfs of course is what everybody
remembers the different personalities
the different ways they're drawn the
fact that their emotional status also
happens to be their names that's what
the kids enjoy adults can enjoy the
artistry a little bit
not just the bright colors a pretty
background but also some of the scary
images they have well the story itself
is not especially dark it was pretty
ballsy to throw in some of this really
creepy imagery the queen is a villain
when you really analyze it is a pretty
boring villain she doesn't say much she
doesn't do much just a really vain woman
there's nothing really that fascinating
in the kids film but what keeps her
pretty enjoyable again is the animation
she's just drawing great I mean she has
this permanent frown on her face I'm
trying to think if I ever saw her smile
in the film and of course the design of
her after the transformation is just
awesome he used to scare the crap
underneath when I was a kid but in
general does Snow White hold up as a
film even if you emotionally
disconnected from the fact that you saw
when you were a child
well the key word there is emotion much
like The Wizard of Oz or even where the
wild things are this is a film that is
entirely fueled on emotion logic plays
very little part in it and to be honest
I find films like that very fascinating
they don't give you what you logically
are ethically want to see they give you
what your emotions want to see like the
prince comes kisses her and they ride
off into the castle well okay how did he
find her where did he come from
did they ever have a conversation in the
movie doesn't make sense that they would
ride off together of course not but
that's not what your emotions want to
see they want to see the happiest of
endings after the saddest and darkest of
moments oh yeah don't think this scene
didn't me up you can keep ambe's
mom you can keep Simba's dad this is the
scene that rips me to shreds why because
it's like a wake literally down to the
oregon music how much more depressing
can you get the dwarves aren't just
trying
they are sobbing bawling over the fact
that they've lost the only woman that's
ever come into their lives
so of course as a young boy I'm sitting
there thinking up it's just a
cartoon ain't gonna leave an impact on
me oh no not grumpy not grumpy no he was
the tough one
just let your throne right now there's
no purpose in living but that's just how
the film works it did well to help kids
emotionally connect with things that we
weren't often used to connecting with
ensure she comes back to life they live
happily ever have
but we didn't know that even if we did
this is still a pretty sad thing to go
through for a little kid this is pretty
heavy so apart from it just being ground
breaking as the first animated film I
think actually it does hold up for
little kids and I've even argue adults
is it complex no is it engaging no but
it's emotional simplicity does manage to
tap into the audience to a point where
we're not even questioning the obvious
logical problems they're just staring us
in the face creating a world for us
we're happily ever after it's okay to
believe much like how Snow White was
mostly fueled on emotions Pinocchio is
very similar it's not even really based
on a fairy tale it's based on a book and
a very odd deranged dark book as well
yeah the movies dark too but good cut
the books downright sadistic we're in a
fairy tale you just know it's sort of a
magical world more magical things can
happen this world treats it a little
differently
I mean there are magical things like the
Blue Fairy that brings a pump into life
but then how about the fact that there's
just a fox and a cat walking around like
normal people
I remember how blown away they were that
they saw a puppet boy walking around and
all I could think that myself is why
isn't anybody blown away that there's a
giant fox and a giant cat just walking
around well it's just that kind of world
where things like that can happen if
there's anything Disney is good at it's
having us go along with things that
don't make sense this movie does it
pretty well Geppetto makes a puppet boy
wishes one night that he were real and
the Blue Fairy comes and makes it happen
it's ironic because probably the film
should be centered around Geppetto he's
the one that has a past he's the one
that actually has some character
Pinocchio is just sort of born with his
personality so the fact that he has to
learn lessons and be given a conscience
is kind of strange because the Blue
Fairy just sort of made him pumped in
she if you want him to learn lessons why
didn't you just have it where the
lessons were already learned but again
I'm
totally overanalyzing this Pinocchio
comes across a bunch of strange
adventures and learns a bunch of lessons
along the way and the visuals they use
to heaven when these lessons sticks with
us even today knows growing longer when
you're lying turning into a donkey when
you've been bad
you don't forget strangeness like this
that often Pinocchio was a pretty
likable character and I like the fact
that they do make him for lack of a
better term a real boy he isn't just
pitch perfect he is gullible he does
want to do bad things sometimes it
doesn't mean he's a rotten kid it just
means he's a kid what sets him apart
though is that he does learn his lesson
and he does try to do better he has a
conscience named Jiminy Cricket who I'm
just gonna say out there I never enjoyed
even as a kid yeah I know that means I
have no heart and I'm going to hell or
whatever you want to say but I just
don't like this guy I just didn't find
that charming I didn't find him that
funny his voice sort of grated on me but
he sings that one song and everybody's
plenty in his hands I don't know I was
always waiting for Pinocchio to step on
him again the creepy imagery is sort of
opt-in this would be much like it wasn't
Snow White except this time is to have
everything always turning out okay this
time it wasn't always okay a bunch of
misbehaving boys are brought to an
amusement park and then turned into
donkeys where they're gonna be used in
binding shams and that's it you never
see them again the guy running the place
is never defeated the boys can't talk
anymore God knows what they're doing
with the ones who can it's pretty
friggin grim as kids films go first
however it does come back to the typical
Disney formula after a relatively
exciting climax Pinocchio gets mashed
into a bunch of rocks and loses his life
again he can spin his head around but
some frogs kills an enemy but the Blue
Fairy comes back and sees his sacrifice
and brings it back everybody in the
audience is filled with joy and of
course Jiminy Cricket sings that song
that nowadays is almost causing some
controversy okay not major controversy
but people have been debating whether or
not this is a good message this is the
song that Disney used all the time it's
practically their biggest trademark but
some people think that just promotes
laziness or a lying belief that
everything will be okay if you just
believe hard enough
you could make that argument I have yet
to see a kid that totally fell for this
or even more depressing an adult I think
kids are smarter than we give them
credit for kids are always gonna be
aware that there's bad things in the
world
there's things they're gonna be afraid
of and that closing their eyes and
wishing isn't always gonna solve a
problem I think most people connect to
it because it's a symbol of hope rather
than realistic planning that sometimes
unexpected good things can happen and
they can come out of nowhere they can
come when you least expect it so never
give up the idea that all hope is gone I
don't know that's what I got out of it I
think that's what most people get out of
it I mean I think that's what most
people get out of the film as well it
runs the Disney game at that most of us
enjoy at times bright and colorful but
other times dark and scary threatening
and doubtful but always with that ray of
hope that sees us there does it always
make a whole lot of sense but we create
a world where it doesn't need to it's a
world where anything can happen even
when you'll be suspect
[Music]
riding high with the success of Snow
White and Pinocchio it's interesting
that Disney decide to do something 100%
different for their third film Fantasia
doesn't have a narrative story hell it
doesn't even have any dialogue apart
from the host it's just an experiment of
taking classical music and combining it
with great Disney animation it's not one
story is several stories a half the time
they're not even really stories the
opening is just a collection of abstract
imagery that goes along with the music
like what your mind might be thinking
when hearing it for the first time and I
friggin love it it's not just one my
favorite Disney films it's one of my
favorite films period remember what I
was saying before about emotional
simplicity you could argue that this is
the film that masters it whereas I
described both Snow White and Pinocchio
as emotional stories this is what I like
to call an emotional experience it's not
based on narrative as much as moments
and life is made up a very unique moment
so I don't think there's really any
problem and putting them together in a
movie especially they do get an
emotional response sometimes it creates
a confusing response like the one with
the dinosaurs I never know how to feel
watching that sometimes they're
threatening sometimes they're cute and
then through the course of the piece
they're just gone I remember as a kid I
had no idea what to think about it's
just sort of something that happened and
you draw your own conclusions so
definitely do have a flowing narrative
like the most famous one The Sorcerer's
Apprentice this is actually how the film
came about Disney just want to make this
short with Mickey Mouse as a magician
but as the expenses for it got bigger
and bigger they finally just shrugged
and said hey while we do a couple of
these and just turn it into a flick the
result is some booming fantastic music
with some booming fantastic animation I
think sometimes just the falling of
leaves can be so much more powerful than
the emotional conflict that a character
is going through if the film is done
right it can suck you into something so
simple and yet so oddly profound and
Disney animators were great at that they
could find the ballet the movement the
music anything that was poetic in well
really anything even just the changing
of seasons
I stayed this before but my absolute
favorite is the ending both a Night on
Bald Mountain and the Ave Maria even if
you don't have a religious background
just the very basic emotional
levels they have here a really high the
contrast in putting these two together
is just brilliant and the belief in
something much darker than you can
imagine or more inspiring than you can
imagine is definitely there
Disney want to do a lot more of these
and have this be a continuing film
series but sadly the film didn't make
the money that it needed oh it made a
lot of money it was like the second or
third highest grossing film that year
but it didn't matter the film cost a
fortune to make him financially it just
didn't make sense to make anymore they
didn't make one sequel years later
though we'll get to that while they come
around to it for this film though
Fantasia is a powerhouse of art in fact
it's actually like going to an art
museum they accept with motion and music
as you can imagine though it's not as
weird for kids as the other Disney boys
there's nothing really troubling or bad
about it that kids can't watch I
remember watching Bald Mountain flying
when I was younger but would be except
to a maybe Sorcerer's Apprentice there's
nothing here that's immediately geared
towards them this was the animated
Disney film almost strictly for adults
and while kids could watch it it wasn't
exactly their film it was more for the
grown-ups and those who loved it really
loved it and it still continues to be
one of my faves
[Music]
well after Fantasia gave a disappoint
turnout at the box office I seen Disney
had to go back to the traditional
narrative Dumbo was the fourth film they
ever released it's a curious choice
because well it is artistically
interesting at times it's not anything
really groundbreaking snow-white
Pinocchio and Fantasia you could
definitely argue broke some new ground
Dumbo is just for your typical kids but
it's not bad actually something I always
noticed about Dumbo is that Dumbo is
never actually the focus he doesn't even
talk he just sort of walks around
looking cute I mean worries he's big
eyed curious and all those are things
you expect at Disney characters but the
focus of the movie is the rest of the
world the world of the circus the world
of the animals the world of getting
drunk it's all about strange visuals
he's very much the observer not the
focus but hey it's fine by me I love
weird imagery especially if it's brought
to us by Disney the story is very basic
an elephant gives birth to a little
elephant that's born with big ears he's
considered an outcast and often gets
into trouble for it while one kid goes
too far and making fun of him the mother
takes the guy and starts beating a crab
huh plus she gets thrown away in the
cellar and Dumbo is left on his own just
with one little friend a circus for us
the rest of the movie is just things
going wrong weird people and weird
things approaching him and
looking confused again I don't have a
problem with it it's done well it's done
reasonably well it's just a weird
strange environment that they built it's
fine because most posters show Dumbo
flying but really he doesn't fly until
the last 10 minutes it just proves to be
your basic remote the Red Nosed Reindeer
story and it works well enough like I
said the weird angles and often bizarre
tone really help to give the film a very
interesting identity energy sort of sets
it apart from the other Disney films now
there is big debate about whether or not
the crows in this movie are racist
obviously they're all played by black
actors and they do use slang and say the
word brother everyone but they never
pulled it like they did song in the
south and some of the other racially
insensitive cartoons and from the
standpoint of just a dumb white kid I
thought they were cool they hit style
they had class they're the ones that
made humble fly what's not to light
their friggin awesome
now again I'm speaking as a dumb white
kid maybe there's something there I'm
missing but for me personally I never
saw the pink elephant scene though
entirely pointless is friggin awesome I
love the scene as a kid I loved it now
it's weird it's drained its kind of dark
it's almost creepy but it's also very
enjoyable the animation is flowing the
weird designs they come up with are just
surreal it's just pure craziness and
yeah there's really no point to it but I
friggin love it they do have some
emotional scenes to the scene where
Dumbo hugs is all there is one of those
big tearjerkers that every girl I know
always goes and nuts whatever they see
and like I said before the world they
created for Dumbo is always big massive
and friend
so when you get to the happy Pappy
points that's all the more enjoy overall
Dumbo's a decent it's not up to par with
some of the more traditional Disney
films but I don't think it was meant to
me he sort of set its own rules and it
stuck with it I think it's pretty
awesome for that it's a fun film with
some fancy
[Music]
well I can't talk about this movie
unless I show this clip there's really
no point in hiding and we all know what
happens to Bambi's mom in this movie and
it messed up so many kids for life but
is that the only reason to enjoy Bambi
the answer is obviously no not only is
the art in this movie just fantastic I
mean good god you just feel like you're
in nature throughout this entire film
but it's the first time Disney has ever
done a coming to age story and it does
it very well where Disney's always been
good at creating villains and
threatening obstacles to go up against
they knew to keep that to a minimum in
this movie the villain is ma'am and you
never see but just the mere threat of
him is enough to be intimidating
everybody talks about the mother's death
but some of these other scenes can get
pretty damn intense like most of the
early Disney films it mixes bright and
colorful with darkened mommy kill but
let's be honest it's not the death of
the mother that gets us it's the fact
that there was such a strong connection
between her and the Sun that's why it
messes us up and I also like the fact
that the father is almost never around
and when he is baby's almost afraid of
it a fascinating dysfunctional family
that may or may not be to be but that's
sort of up for debate and that's one of
the reasons I do like this film so much
the answers are not clear-cut hell even
the questions aren't clear-cut it's just
the life of this deer and all those
typical children's cliches that you see
in other kids films oh hell you see
another adult films for that matter are
not here and thank God because you know
what this is enough sometimes just
showing someone or something live their
life is all unique life is interesting
life has problems life doesn't always
resolve itself in a clever and poetic
way life doesn't always have heroes life
doesn't always have villains so because
of that as you'd imagine there's less of
an emphasis on story and more on
character while Bambi is not the most
fascinating of characters he's supposed
to be sort of the every guy he's the
blank slate that's supposed to absorb
love fear sadness happiness and whatever
other emotions you can connect with I'd
be lying if I said I watched this one a
lot in fact it's probably one of the
Disney films I watched the least though
I do open it but I definitely respect
him more than I do view it I guess
there's only so many cutesy wutesy
scenes I could sit through but mine are
done well and with purpose the second
half is that - where I start to get more
interested I mean you know after that
scene I like seeing Bambi grow up I like
seeing what he's become and I like
seeing what he's going to make of itself
it's not a lot of films with the lack of
really complex characters is made up for
and how much complexity they put into
the backgrounds of the covers at the
time the sceneries give you the emotions
now like a film I can do that without
cheating on the character necessarily
the emotions are there in the character
they're just emphasized by the
surroundings
Bambi is chock full event heavy
atmosphere in a heavy environment it's
easily one of Disney's finest
[Music]
I'll be honest when I was looking
through the list of Disney animated
films and I came across some people some
Pecos I never even heard of him
I thought I knew most of the Disney and
drawn films but this one totally slipped
my mind
and to be fair there's kind of good
reason it's not very long I don't even
think it's really a full-length motion
picture I think it's about 40 minutes
and on top of that it's just weird
premise a bunch of the Disney animators
decide to fly to places like Brazil and
Titicaca and so forth to give them
inspiration for their cartoons and
that's it it's literally just the
animators going around doing drawings
and showing you the cartoon that came up
with does it really count as a movie I
don't know I can see that much more as a
feature read or a making-of or a
behind-the-scenes bit but as a movie
it's not very interesting maybe if we
got to know the animators a little more
shot a little better but as is it just
sort of looks like someone's vacation
videos with just cartoons the only cool
thing about it that you don't get a
little bit of culture they show you what
different words mean they show you
different parts of that land some things
you are getting a little bit of an
education out but even the animation is
just their normal cartoon animation I
love a cartoon animation but to see an
entire movie like man like naive an
entire movie 40 minutes heck even the 40
minutes isn't entirely animated it seems
like kind of a letdown I don't know I'm
not sure how to judge it seeing how it's
not even a motion picture length but I
often see it on the list of animated
Disney films so I guess I'll include it
here and actually this is the birthplace
of that one Green Parrot I think most
people think he came from three copy
arrows but nope this is actually where
he was born
yes that's kind of
the only that I remember really enjoying
was when they were singing the song
where's it and you see this paintbrush
go through an actually paint presume
this is awesome Disney doing what
awesome Disney does dinking shapes and
colors and plankton you think you're
looking at tree but maybe you're looking
at a bird you think it's a bunch of
bananas but with a splash of black
you're looking at two cans stuff like
that is great and the rest of the film
was like that maybe I'd enjoy it but as
is it's pretty forgettable it might be
good to put on just as a time waster for
your kids like I said it does have a
little bit of culture in it but as a
movie it's not that groundbreaking if
you just want to say you've seen them
all go check it out but aside from that
I'd say it's probably a decent couple
Yarrow's is probably much better known
than saludos amigos but to be fair
they're not that much different true and
comparing the two that does seem to be a
lot more passion thrown into this one
it's longer there's more energy and as
far as their basic cartoon animation
goes this is some of their best I mean
the motion and the line work just leaps
off the screen sometimes look at how
fast they're doing
much like saludos amigos there is really
a story oh well in about as much as it's
just Donald opening some presents yeah
that's the story isn't I'm riveting he
gets a package on its birthday which it
turns out Friday the 13th bitch it is no
lab and each present it turns out as a
presentation on some place he's never
been to before I like the last film
they're shorts there's songs
there's down dog acting like Donald Duck
and at first I was kind of getting into
it I was kind of enjoying all the
randomness mixed in with the music and
like I said that really fast-paced
animation and the stories were a lot
more memorable - there's one about a
penguin trying to get to warmer climate
another one about a burro who can fly
but then the story sort of stopped and
we get that green parrot again him and
down the look around Brazil a bit they
dance they sing they have fun I guess
and then he opens the last package and
we have that I'm not sure what he is but
he comes out to sing about Mexico and
literally the last third of this movie
is just Donald trying to get laid every
time you see him he's fawning over a
woman for women and just trying to get
somebody to tickle his tail feathers
two-thirds of the movie is pretty much
like just being at a party which at
first sounds awesome but at some point
you kind of want to leave that party and
find something else or talk to somebody
or take a breather or I don't know but
there's only so long you can do it and
that's the problem with this but after a
while it gets tiring the animation
continues to impress as well as some
really good live-action mixing but
you're just sort of watching people
dance most of the time and for a few
minutes it's fine but for a whole second
half of a movie it gets pretty old
pretty fast then we just cut to the
three of them acting goofy and abstract
land again they jump around shoot some
guns fire off some fireworks and that's
it
that's the movie
there's a lot of things I really like
about this film I like a lot of the
scenes I like a lobby animations and the
short stories which is why I hate it so
much when I see it all together because
it suddenly becomes boring this is one
of those movies we're on the Disney
Channel they would shop it up and they
would just show it as little shorts on
their cartoon shows and that's really
where it belongs I can't see this really
functioning as a film maybe if they went
for more of a Cirque du Soleil thing or
kept a little bit more focus or even
lack of focus just something that went
all the way here it seems like they kind
of want to do short stories and now they
kind of want to do it as one long party
and now they kinda wanna make it
educational but now they kind of want to
make it silly the only thing that's
consistently good as I said before is
the animation which is really stylized
and fun but for me I don't think that
holds the film if you want to see it
just for the motion and the cool
drawings say maybe check it out but even
then that's a big baby there's other
Disney films that do animation better
and they have good story and characters
to go along with it so I probably just
recommend those but if you're curious
enough it does have some good moments
take that from what it's
[Music]
it's ironic that Disney decided not to
do any more of the Fantasia series
because for the next couple of films
they be trying endlessly to try and
recreate it make my music was probably
the first attempt to try and do that if
I was sore about similar formula to what
Three Caballeros was doing just tying
together a series of shorts with a
certain kind of music although three
copy arrows where they had a character
at least tying the stories together
though loosely this one they just show
the shorts again much like Fantasia
except the music isn't classical music
it's more music that was popular at the
time in fact some of it if I understand
correctly was left over from Fantasia
the animation for blue Bay you actually
makes it into this point which was
originally supposed to be featured a
sequel to Fantasia except instead of
using the classical music they use a
song instead later the original will be
released on DVD and it's a lot better
make my music is probably closer to what
Three Caballeros was trying to be sort
of a fun series of short stories they
were very loosely tied together with one
theme in this one you guessed it music
well some classical does make it in for
example we do a Peter in the wall though
it does have a narrator as well but it's
okay we also have a short that really
seems to have nothing to do with music
remember the cartoon might be Casey up
to bat yeah it's from this it's a great
story and it's hilarious but what's it
have to do with music is talking and
rhyming really the same well however you
want to take it it's still great to
watch here the short stories work a lot
better
some just create atmosphere others tell
a full narrative and they're all pretty
solid if you think of any part I
particularly didn't like favorite
moments in Flook Casey again Peter and
wall
but by far my favorite is the singing
wheel with all the singing voices done
by one person throughout the entire
thing that is awesome
I know a lot of people probably haven't
seen this cartoon so without giving
anything away let's just say that sad
face yeah big clue and it's another one
of those bittersweet moments that
probably leaves a few kids confused but
I like that it wasn't totally sad but
it's definitely not happy either
and on top of that you're getting some
great music and one hell of a great
singer modern to classic to jazz they
cover a pretty impressive gambit and
while nothing hits quite as potent as
Fantasia does it is still pretty enjoy
this is another example of a bunch of
cartoons that were taken from this movie
and then chopped up into shorts and
there's a reason they work really well
so if you ever want to see them all
together
check this movie out it's a good one
[Music]
bond and fancy-free only one thing could
be gayer than that title and there is
yes I said before I'm not a huge fan of
Jiminy Cricket but luckily he doesn't
have that much to do with this just like
the other films there's no one story but
in this there's not really a bunch of
them either there's only two and Jiminy
Cricket
for whatever reason hosts them it's
strange that they would actually call
this movie fun and fancy-free instead
just the two titles it's not like make
mine music where if you listed all the
titles it wouldn't be enough room here
there's only two Bongo and Jack and the
Beanstalk heck that's a shorter title
than Ichabod and mr. toad they could
have done it but hang with it how did
the stories hold up well as the other
Disney stories go even for the short
ones it's nothing that special they're
okay though the first one is called
Bongo it's about a bear who used to work
in the circus but escapes to live in the
wild he finds he doesn't quite fit in
but things change when he comes across a
female there but then he gets confused
when she starts beating the up but
then the movie so colorfully tells us
that the way bears show that they love
each other is beating the out of
each other makes sense to me yeah even
as a kid I'm still not sure I buy it now
but it makes for a cute song that's the
best way to describe the first short
cute I really liked it as a kid
but looking back does go on a little too
long if they were gonna do this and make
it work that you'd either make it its
own movie with much more characters or
make it a lot shorter then there's a
really weird transition where Jiminy
Cricket is somehow invited to a party a
party where puppets come to life and
strange creepy men do weird sounds with
their hands and the parents are nowhere
to be seen
yeah this would not fly today
Vidia you look so sweet I said I think
you look so sweet yes but that segues
into Jack and the Beanstalk the first
appearance of Mickey Mouse in any movies
since Fantasia
believe it or not the last time you ever
hear Walt Disney do it voice we also get
Goofy and Donald into the mix as it's
pretty much just the straightforward
story of Jack and the Beanstalk not
really any major differences that's the
only thing that really stands out about
it is the giant who is sort of this
enjoyable dude and they added this
really weird plot device where he could
change into anything isn't that strange
he's already a giant why do you have to
give him more magical stuff being a
giant's enough on top of that they don't
really do anything with it there's a
whole Shea scene at the end where he's
trying to get up but wouldn't just make
more sense if you turn to a cheetah or
something the food doesn't quite have
the flow or creativity that they might
music have and to be honest I don't know
what the connection is with all these
things you have Jiminy Cricket than a
bear from a circus into the wild then a
creepy man with puppets and then Jack
and the Beanstalk how's it all tied
together individually they work okay
that's cartoons but I don't think
there's enough of them to really warrant
a film or if they did pick two they'd
have to do ones that are particularly
unique or particularly cinematic and the
earth is really hard again they're not
bad they're just not anything that
special but they have their own charm
and likability - oh so I guess they work
out you'd say it's probably better just
to rent them individually and skip the
middle parts but that's just me if it
looks good to you you'll probably like
[Music]
now we have melody time which is so
similar to make my music that actually
so wondering why they didn't just call
it make my music - I mean it's almost
identical different variations of songs
most of the modern sun' by modern
singers a little bit of poetry thrown in
and even some straightforward stories
it's pretty much the exact same thing
and just like make my music that's what
works pretty good - you do have your
straightforward narrative some of them
more forgettable than others but you
also have your selections of
straightforward music and even sometimes
even straightforward poetry the poem as
lovely as a tree signa is especially
nice it's just the Disney animators
drawing what they hear as the poem is
rent with a nice soothing music thrown
over it it works pretty well there's
also a really cool section called bumble
boogie which reminds me a lot of the
pink elephant sequence it's just a bee
flying around - a whacked out version of
flight of the bumblebee as the music is
literally trying to destroy it
it's really chaotic at least as some fun
imagery the one that probably stands out
the most is the Johnny Appleseed walk
when I was a kid I really liked well
it's a teenager I got a little bit more
cynical and started making fun of it now
that I'm older I actually find myself
really liking it again it's got some
real heavy atmosphere some real heavy
visuals and some of those backgrounds
are just incredible
yeah it's still a little corny and I do
make fun of it sometimes but it still
holds up it's the size and scope that
they give something that seems so
relatively simple and yet they show that
took so much dedication that image of
the apple trees becoming the clouds as
one of the most surreal things I've ever
seen I remember it even stayed in my
mind as little kid and it really really
is ripping
in fact it's so good it probably could
have been its own movie I'm sorry
wondering why they tucked it away in
here and then the last segment they end
on is Pecos Bill some through a lot of
folk and country music this is also fun
too and really creative but again why do
they end the film on these I mean it's
funny it's enjoyable and it's catchy but
dude did you see the Appleseed one I
mean that was far superior Pecos Bill
just ends on a yeah I don't even know
what note I'm not sure if it's sad I'm
not sure if it's happy it's just kind of
odd like I said I don't have a problem
with it I just don't know why they
closed on it but either way melody time
has some really good shorts in it as
well as some good music and really great
animation the atmosphere is really heavy
in this one again maybe not Fantasia
heavy but there are points where I hits
that traditional Disney charm that only
Disney can have and they've recreated
quite well here melody time is
definitely one to check out
you
[Music]
so we went from a bunch of shorts to
just to to a bunch of shorts to just to
again only this time there's a feeling
that the stories they think we're much
more out of the norm these were really
fairy tales they were sort of classic
stories both have their funny of beep
moments but both have this very
underlining dark tone throughout the
whole thing even the setting for the
narrators is a little it's just this
dark dark library you don't even see the
narrator it's just these books sort of
floating in the stained glass window
with a candle in it when I was a kid I
loved it as an adult I still love it but
heck let's talk about them individually
you got The Wind in the Willows which
when you get down to it is another very
strange book not that animals are
walking and talking that's not the weird
part it's the fact that everybody else
in the world is human and not just that
they're to scale the rat is literally
the size of a rat that just looks so odd
but the rest of the story seems to
follow pretty closely to the book you
got toad who's an extremist with
anything anything that's new anything
that's hot he's all over it mania as the
Brits like to call it and he suddenly
gets obsessed with motor cars
so he makes a really stupid deal with a
guy named weepy who I'm sure it's some
sorry ethnic stereotype in that he hands
over told whole in exchange for the car
but in court weepy tells a different
story and says the toad stole the car
which gets him thrown in jail and only
his friends are able to save moly and
Brad are a lot of fun toad is enjoyably
crazy and even that horse gets a few
good winters next you have the legend of
sleepy ho which in terms of story layout
even to the original book is so odd to
me but I really love it because then
most of the short is just a Chabad crane
and how he interacts with the people in
the town
he has only he has a girlfriend it's a
little bit of a love triangle and most
of it is done through mine yet Bing
Crosby narrating it but for the most
part people don't really talk and yet so
much character still comes out of them
including the fact that something I
never knows as a kid
kind of a dick I mean we look at what he
wants to do he wants to marry this woman
and mainly get her money I mean he's
already fantasizing her father being out
of the picture I think a lot of people
when they look back think of Ichabod
Crane is just this innocent that gets
killed by the Headless Horseman but no
he was actually sort of a bastard
which for Disney is kind of interesting
as well the few times where you actually
have sort of a jerk be your lead in fact
you couldn't make the argument that Brom
bones though he's a bit of a bully is
much more of a good guy I mean he
doesn't do anything really wrong or at
least not as wrong as Ichabod after all
we know maybe he'd make a better
boyfriend who knows but of course the
part everyone remembers is the built up
appearance of the Headless Horseman my
god that laughs is cool I think it's one
of those rare times that a lot of kids
found themselves both scared and
laughing at the same time the climax is
a lot of fun that way it's sort of like
evil did too in fact I'd be shocked if
director Sam Raimi didn't take a lot of
the atmosphere and tone directly from
this cartoon
[Music]
it's just your classic ghost story with
a classic ghost story ending and the two
seem to go actually pretty well together
let's take advantage of the fact that
it's cinematic and they can get a lot of
fun angles and they also stick true to
their stories as well as taking some
creative liberties
whenever anyone thinks wind in the
willow or Sleepy Hollow these are
usually the first two versions that come
in from and that's probably not so bad
it's good to read the originals of
course but these are pretty good
adaptation it's heavy on the dark but
also big on the last either one is great
on its own but back-to-back they work
just as good
[Music]
Cinderella every little girl's dream
come true after six films of not having
a continuing story run all the way
through this was finally a return to the
three act structure Cinderella the
famous fairy tale tells the story of a
young woman who's been turned into a
maid by her stepmother and her evil
stepsisters her bunch of animal friends
help her out of course and try to keep
things jolly but when the night of the
ball approaches and she isn't able to go
her fairy godmother appears and gives
her a dressing carriage to make it up
there I guess by this point it was
trying to return to the roots of Snow
White you got the pretty damsel you have
an animal sidekicks they have a softer
more realistic human being as the being
star as opposed to a company animal and
of course you have the evil terrifying
villains
I guess Cinderella is one of those it
gets hard done a lot from being very
anti feminist just wait around wishing
your dreams will come true first of all
it didn't Pinocchio start that and
second I don't know from a male point of
view growing up I never thought she was
that bad I always saw a lot of patience
with her I mean yeah I guess you never
really did anything but at the same time
the fact that she was willing to put up
with so much and yet still find some
happiness in her everyday life there's
got to be some really good values in
there as a character there isn't really
too much else to her but to be honest
the virtues I listed before I think
those are enough the villain is great I
love that by simply having control over
one person's life this can be one of the
great Disney baddies the way she's
animated the way she stares the way she
smiles she's a great one
the songs of course everybody knows
bibbidi-bobbidi-boo and so forth and the
animation is sort of a nice return to
those softer colors they were made
popular in Snow White
Fantasia what am i main problems again
though is the prince god
does he even get a line in this movie
his dad actually has more dialogue in
fact the movie is much more about the
dad wanting him to fall in love than him
actually wanting to fall in love maybe
making an angle from the princes point
view might have been more interesting
but maybe if you did you'd see just how
really twisted and kind of sick this
story is hey he found a woman strictly
based on sight hey he knew her for a few
hours and they've decided she's the one
Hey all she left is a shoe and yet
somehow that's gonna determine which
woman you're going to marry Hey
coincidentally the shoe size can only
fit one friggin woman in the entire
world and thank God it just happened to
be the one you fell in love with yeah I
guess it is a little screwed as the
Disney films go especially the ones that
are used the traditional princessy
formula this one's okay it's got some
really good moments some really good
song sequences and like I said a really
cool villain but a lot of it also seems
like filler just the animals are walking
around being goofy having fun when
really you could have been spending that
time developing some of the other
characters like oh I don't know again
don't forget prance but the artwork is
pretty impressive too watching it again
I really like the scale if they give a
lot of these houses and castles actually
do make it seem rather massive and this
is before white screen it's the basic
return to the classic fairy tale and it
does it pretty decently and any problems
it does have story wise I think you can
attribute to just the time period and
well the fact that it is a fairy tale
a lava we're just sort of written it I
think it holds up okay one of my
personal favorites but it's definitely
pretty
[Music]
whenever people hear the title alice in
wonderland' usually the first thing they
think of is the disney version and yeah
actually that's not such a bad version
to think of a story about a young girl
who finds herself trapped in a very
strange mysterious land is much more
based on the journey than finding twists
or turns the character of Alice it's a
bit of a blank slate
she's the normal person that's supposed
to play off all the weird strange things
that she comes across it plays very much
like a roadtrip movie you come across
something strange you have an encounter
with it and then you move on to the next
strange thing like I said the focus is
not the twists and turns but all the
oddities that she comes across it's like
Dante's Inferno it's more a study of
what you're seeing than what you're
experiencing but with that said the girl
that got the play Alice is actually
pretty good her name's Katherine
Beaumont and she does a really good job
actually giving some character to this
person the dialogue from Alice in
Wonderland is not easy to recite and
it's not easy to make casual she does a
pretty good job she's curious she's
polite she's nice but can be pushed to
her limits she tries to join in the fun
but often just Minds herself too
frustrated and she's also very logical
which makes a lot of sense in a story
like this because this is a world where
logic almost has no place my favorite
characters are your favorite characters
I love the Mad Hatter I love the March
Hare I love the Cheshire Cat they're all
absolutely crazy but at the same time I
think the fun with them is that you
never know if they're threatening or not
their mood swings are just so fast and
you never know if something really
dangerous is gonna happen or if they're
just playing along at the time I don't
even think they know the Queen is one of
my favorite funny villains actually
watching her again I realized I actually
did take a lot of than this dowager
critic from this character just how
quickly she can turn from calm and
collected to just screaming like a
little child
I really do love pathetic whiny brats in
a grown up body but somehow have a ton
of power and I love watching Alice
trying to figure out what's the right
thing to say and right thing to do
because she knows that any second her
head could be gone actually that's a
pretty dark aspect to the story isn't it
how many characters do actually get
their heads chopped off in this movie
just because they don't show it doesn't
mean it isn't happening it's pretty grim
Wonderland itself is very different from
other interpretations it doesn't have a
bright colorful background it's very
black most of the backgrounds are black
but that's always great because when
color does come in it's always bright
it's always clashing and it always pops
some people have problems that they cut
out too much from the original books and
well it's a Disney film and an anime
wanted that you sir have to get whatever
you're given I will say with all the
forced Disney sequels out there how come
this never got one there is literally a
sequel book to Alice in Wonderland why
did they just change things around a bit
and start putting in some of the other
characters like the night the turtle the
Gryphon there's a ton of areas you could
go with this but oh well what I do like
about Alice in Wonderland is that it
does make the transition into movie form
that's the trap I think a lot of other
movie versions fall into it's that they
try to follow the book a little too
closely ironically with the Tim Burton
one I don't think they followed it
enough but I've complained about bad
enough Alice in Wonderland is creative
it looks great it's a wonderful journey
movie and the majority of it works
because the main character is just so
likable I have very few complaints about
except honestly I would have liked to
have seen more but I guess that's a good
complaint to have if you're looking for
a movie that's big on Story surprise
isn't character development this is
probably not the place to look but I
think most people going into Alice in
Wonderland know what they're gonna get
and in my opinion this is one of the
better versions
I always said that Peter Pan was sort of
like every little boys fantasy I mean
think about you got pirate you got
flying you got Indians you got faraway
lands you got mermaids if somehow they
worked in cowboys and spaceman this
movie will be set and for what the story
is Disney does it pretty well
they've course put some changes here and
there but they still get the
characteristics of these people down
really great pan himself is very cocky
and sure of himself and I have to admit
he has a little bit of product of the
times something about that voice in the
way he looks you can definitely tell it
was done in the 50s of course that's why
I like him I tell him to the Lost Boys
but he never uses anchoring catchphrases
or anything
Wendy once again is portrayed by Kathryn
Beaumont again sort of taking your bland
typical innocent and turning into
something really entertaining okay
surprise they didn't use there anymore
films up to us you got John the geek and
Michael the cute innocent they all go
off on an adventure to never Neverland
where they never have to grow up The
Lost Boys are typical delinquents and
the Pirates are typical pirates of what
I really loved about this movie is
Captain Hook again this is sort of the
Captain Hook most people think of when
they think of Peter Pan threatening but
he's also really really funny
Smee as well as sort of the definitive
Smee he wants be mean-spirited but he's
just too bumbling and nice plus when you
put the two of them together with the
crocodile dude this is some of the best
slapstick you'll ever see the timing the
pacing the expressions it kills me every
single time I watch these scenes
[Music]
the romance between Wendy and Peter is
just perfect it's not overdone they
never actually share a kiss on screen
it's very much done like how real little
kids fall in love girl often wants it
more and the boy doesn't know what the
hell to think of it Tinkerbell is a nice
bitchy character that also gets a
Redemption at the end and the Indians
they're definitely an archetype of what
we thought Native Americans were at that
point I don't know it's sort of like the
black crows from Dumbo I thought they
were cool Peter Pan seems to get the
childlike adventure down pretty well for
little kids it's pretty gender-neutral
the girls can get into the romance and
the mermaids and the flying and such
well the boys can get into the sword
fighting the pirates and all that good
stuff the energy is great the
imagination is great it's just a good
old-fashioned fun kids it's definitely
one of Disney's most biggest trademarks
for a reason
[Music]
they mean the Tramp was one of the first
movies I ever saw in theaters
so naturally I loved it when I was a
little kid the story of an upper-class
female dog that comes across a low-down
scroungy male dog is about as typical as
it gets at first they don't like each
other but a few situations forced them
together and if they get to hang out or
they really decide that they were meant
for each other there's some differences
to this usual story that I like like the
fact that I enjoy when they first see
each other it's not love at first sight
like some of the other Disney films if
anything he just sees her in passing it
just strikes up a conversation it's not
even a pleasant conversation he's
talking about how the baby is gonna take
over her life and that she's never gonna
be the center of attention anymore and
then he just leaves honestly if you
didn't know the story going in you
probably wouldn't have guessed they'd be
together by me I sort of like that
there's also a bunch of clever little
touches to like I enjoy how the dogs
interpret everything like how the main
character thinks that the name of her
vulnerability simply because that's what
they call each other all the time
oh darling as Disney films go it's cute
nothing that spectacular
he keeps your interests you want to know
what's gonna happen but there's no real
big surprises or any phenomenal bits of
animation or well just so you think that
really stands out that much for what it
is it's a decent film it did give us
that great sight I don't know is that
racist now - I'm sure but it's the one
song everybody homes when they're
leaving the theatre so that's gotta
count for something
it is nice that they don't go for a
straight-up villain in the movie or any
of those four story cliches well except
maybe one or two but they're pretty
downplayed the movie is pretty much just
a series of moments but they're nice
moments and I don't recall them ever
being really boring so overall I think
it's okay I don't think it's one I'll be
watching over and over like the other
Disney films but it holds up decent if
you're a dog walker or even not check it
out is worth an hour and a half you're
doing
[Music]
Sleeping Beauty this movie always
astounds me and what a colossal epic and
what a colossal mess it is both at the
same time first let's look at the good
stuff the artwork for example is a very
different take for Disney the
backgrounds never look three-dimensional
but they're not supposed to it's
supposed to be very much like to add the
street work or like paintings you'd see
in a medieval cast it was a very
different approach and it looks very
nice though I guess at times it can be a
little distracting for some viewers I
personally don't mind though let's also
look at the side characters the fairies
are great they have to hide the Princess
Aurora for sixteen years to keep her
away from the evil of Maleficent
well again is friggin great I mean one
of the best villains top three easily
it's a villain that's evolved almost
entirely from the voice acting and the
animation cuz be fair her motivations
not very strong she gets snubbed at a
party that's it but the extreme she'll
go to get revenge
now that's friggin awesome she's classy
she's despicable she's quiet she's loud
she's subtle she's over-the-top
she's everything you want in a villain
she can wave her hand to make something
move or she can turn into a
fire-breathing dragon friggin awesome
the music is also fantastic taken from
one of the best-known ballets under the
same name it leads to some memorable
songs as well as some great climax music
in fact the climax itself is one of
Disney's bests the energy the animation
everything that goes into it is just
fiery blaze
it's always the best part of the movie
every time I watch it
now let's get to the stuff that doesn't
work like the main characters good god
are they boring when I think of the
stereotypical boring princess this is
who I think of she does nothing she has
little to no character she just sort of
sings and looks pretty I don't even
think she's that pretty but how about
the prince he's the dashing hero in the
end surely he must be interesting right
actually he's even more boring do you
realize that the last line he says in
this movie is goodbye father and that's
about halfway through after that
he doesn't get a line he just runs
around swinging his sword that's it at
least she has an excuse she's put to
sleep for the second half him who we get
a grunt or an oomph or absolving there's
also a lot of filler in this movie and
maybe that's one of the reasons why the
main characters are so bland I think
this movie really liked its side
characters much more most the time is
spent with the fairies the villains the
two kings that really doesn't lead to
anything so really it's a very
unbalanced film but again I guess like
most Disney films the stuff that works
well works really really well the
villain is great the fairies are great
the animation is great that ending fight
scene is just friggin fantastic so it's
kind of hard to judge this movie seeing
how not only does they have some good
things but it has some of the best of
any of the Disney films but it goes
beyond just typical visuals it actually
does have some very good characters even
if they are the side characters for that
I think it holds up for several movies I
did see this film quite a few times
growing up and I did like it every time
there's just several scenes I liked a
lot more than others but they are good
scenes and they are good characters so
from a storytelling point of view the
film probably doesn't work but just from
a selfish point of view in terms of
seeing something that you've never seen
before something has done really really
well there's a lot of things to enjoy
even if it turns out on the whole you
don't like the film I still think it's
worth looking at the stuff that's
impressive is still really impressive I
know I'm not done watching it and I'm
sure one or two more views are not far
in my future
[Music]
well I hope you like Dalmatians are
you're really not gonna like this movie
well okay I shouldn't be that mean to it
but let's just be honest it's a bunch of
Dalmatians they walk around they look
cute they talk they bark they know no
just do cutesy stuff if you like that
you're gonna love this film if not it's
a bit of a bore
because there are a few things that
stand out about it like the villain
Cruella De Vil which ever since the
live-action version has become one of
the most infamous villains of all time
and she has a lot of fun it's just a
great design sort of this weak fragile
woman under this gigantic hairy monster
as fur coat she's both glamorous and
hideous at the same time and it leaves a
pretty cool design and the characters a
lot of fun to constantly screaming
constantly yelling but always trying to
look fabulous while doing it her
motivation is to get as many dalmatian
puppies as she can to make a bajillion
fur coats and once 15 puppies of our
main characters get abducted which
somehow makes the front pages for some
reason a search is on to go and find the
rest of the characters are not bad
they're just kind of phoned in the
husband and wife are a typical nice
husband and wife the side characters are
typical sort of Dobby side characters I
think the only one I ever really got
into was the cat because there was just
this feeling he wouldn't never give up I
mean yeah he's constantly screaming he's
constantly running but he's always
sticking with the puppies look at that
they're about to bash their brains on
he's still there trying to protect them
it's awesome go kitty I guess part of
the joke of the movie is how seriously
they're treating the dogs like how the
husband is just as paranoid about the
birth of the puppies as well the dog is
or how what the puppies are kidnapped
the maid goes out screaming into the
streets and like I said it makes
front-page papers no no for me I never
found it that funny so I guess it never
got any laughs I guess the climax is
kind of fun it is rare that you see a
car chase in a Disney film especially
with karela behind of you and I do enjoy
how the car continues to get stripped
down and almost dressed to turn into
just as big a monster as she put aside
from
I don't think it has the charm as
something like lady in the tram head or
even the ennovation for it although I
guess it was sort of groundbreaking and
that they were testing grow no scope and
copying and so forth the comedy puppies
Lincoln Show but I don't know if that
makes it one of the better Disney ones
if you're a dog fan or a Dalmatian fan
you'll probably like it fine but if not
it's not horrible it's just not manage
change take it for what it's worth not
one of my personal sword in the stone
this is one of those movies I both
really love and really hate at the same
time oh baby hates too strong a word but
there's definitely an annoyance to it
okay let's talk about the good stuff
these are very memorable characters
Arthur is a naive innocent boy and
Merlin is sort of this weird eccentric
wizard who's trying to teach him
knowledge and wisdom
it's urban ice having a film about
Arthur that doesn't dive right into the
sword battles and such but instead into
the philosophies of well being a good
king I like how we dive into the
education I like how we dive into him
learning everything but I guess here's
my problem women that's exactly what it
is
it's education and learning things and
it sort of goes at that pace it's kind
of like being in school except you have
an owl and Merlin teaching you stuff as
opposed to your boring teachers but with
that said that is kind of cool but is
that really what kids want to see when
they go to watch a Disney film for me as
a kid I did find myself watching it on
WOD maybe because there was such a
laid-back tone to it I mean yeah Arthur
becomes a bird it becomes a fish it
becomes a squirrel
and that's always great for kids but
nothing truly exciting happens until the
last third when we get our villain mad
madam MIM and even then she's more of a
side character than the main villain
though she is a lot of fun and that
wizard's duel battle scene was awesome I
used to watch that over and over when I
it's creative has just got some great
slams dude when I got older and I saw
that the film is in the video store I
said you know what I do remember that
movie leaving a big impact on me maybe I
should watch it again but when I saw it
again I joined it a little more boring
than I remember the animations not
really spectacular and there's really
the background and I found it wasn't
really learning that much it's got as
good scenes but I don't know if it
really gels as well as it wants it to I
think I admire more what it was trying
to do than the final product but that's
it I do like the relationship between
Arthur and Merlin the side characters
are a lot of fun - so has anyone else
noticed that the boy clearly went
through puberty when he was doing this
voice I've got to get back to the castle
no want me in the kitchen he was a
monster the biggest fish I ever saw
there's literally a scene where they
played two clips of his voice
back-to-back and they don't gel up
listen author actor it sounds like two
different kids but oh well the film is a
bit of a mixed bag but I am glad I saw
it when I was younger I guess I'm glad I
saw when I was older - there's a lot of
creativity and like I said I think it
was kind of neat that they took this
very laid-back tone sometimes I think it
works to its disadvantage I do like it
but I think a lava is more because of
the nostalgia and the idea it's hard to
say whether or not the whole thing is
worth recommending but I will say if you
do go see it you'll definitely get one
or two really creative and enjoyable
[Music]
[Applause]
the Jungle Book was the last anime film
that was made while Disney was alive
which is interesting because the two
films that would follow would steal such
an unbelievable amount of animation from
it and as Disney films go this is
another one that I probably just plays
in the okay category personally I'm not
a huge fan of the more sketchy style of
Disney animation at least not around
this time period then we sort of look
like pencil sketches that were painted
over and never quite looked finished to
me if your favorite great it just
doesn't do much for me but teacher oh so
how's this story well based on Rui our
Kipling's bug though very loosely it
follows the story of a little boy or man
cub as the animals call him named Mowgli
he's raised by a pack of wolves but
suddenly his life is in danger when the
evil tiger Shere Khan is coming to town
Shere Khan hates man and the Wolves know
he'll end up ripping him to shreds if he
ever finds him so a panther named
Bagheera takes Mowgli to the man village
the only problem is Mowgli doesn't want
to go he wants to stay in the jungle and
tries every chance he can to get away
while on the way he comes across a
friendly bear named Baloo a marching
elephant army a crazy ape named King
Louie and a hypnotizing snake named kah
well let's talk about the good stuff the
best thing in this movie is sheer Kon
he's just a great villain he actually
reminds me a lot of Maleficent there's
not really much motivation to him but
just the style and class he has is so
friggin awesome he's so confident in
what a badass he is that it really does
actually come off pretty intimidating he
just has nothing to fear the snake gob
I'm not a main villain he's also pretty
cool some of the best parts of the movie
are just all the jokes they can make
with how long he is don't take that the
wrong way
aside from that the boy is okay the
other characters are okay the songs are
you guessed it okay that's right take it
back the very last song the girl sings
while getting the water actually I think
it's a very nice tune I'd almost like to
hear a different updated version of it
because it actually has a very soothing
melody but aside from that nothing
really stands out too much for me about
this jungle book which is a shame
because the original book is not only
much darker but it's much more
interesting the way the animal world
views the human world is actually sort
of a fascinating commentary
the characters are more developed too
and it follows Mowgli through sort of a
coming-of-age story which is really a
shame because I think Disney could do
the story great Chuck Jones did a
version that was much closer to the book
in a half hour
I found that infinitely more fascinating
than this film as is there's nothing
really bad about the jungle book except
like I said not following the book that
closely but as its own separate thing it
works out fine it's a very basic kids
film what-you-see-is-what-you-get it
kept me entertained as a little kid and
I'm sure you'll keep your kids
entertained as well a few creative
scenes and one or two characters
definitely make it worth a watch
[Music]
if you want to film this sums up all the
forget ability about Disney I probably
pointed the Aristocats I've only seen
this movie once or twice in my life and
every time I have I've totally forgotten
that I even watched it again like most
Disney movies there's nothing really
that terrible about it I just can't find
anything really spectacular about it or
even that good Disney movies like this
really annoy me though because it's just
being cutesy for the sake of being
cutesy okay what's the story this Butler
finds that he's gonna inherit a bunch of
cats and it turns out he hates cats he's
allergic to land can't stand them so he
tries to get rid of them through the
old-fashioned cliche of throwing them
off a bridge which by the way am I the
only one disturbed that that's an
old-fashioned cliche do people actually
do this what's wrong with folks back
then anyway there are these two pretty
funny dogs that chase them down and we
do get a pretty entertaining chase scene
out of it but after that it's just the
cats trying to find their way home and
the other interesting cats that they
come across along the way there's no
depth
there's no intrigue there's no
interesting twists and turns there's no
Bond adventure it's just cats looking
cute and bouncing around - fun music I
don't know even though it's a kid I
remember being really bored by this
movie I hear other people liked it when
they were younger but I don't know many
to like it now that they're older I
actually find it one of the weaker
Disney film simply because it leaves
little to no impact even Disney when it
made its biggest mistakes at least to
let memorable mistakes this one I never
even have any memory of watching yeah
I'm probably being too harsh on it it
probably wasn't meant for much much
younger kids but from Disney I expected
a lot more better story better
characters better animation personally
I'd skip
[Music]
[Applause]
how many of us were introduced to Robin
Hood through the Disney well I can
certainly say I was and it's interesting
because I think this is the only Disney
film where all the characters are anima
morphic life forms oh there's other
movies where they use them but I think
this is the first one where every
character throughout the entire flick is
half-human half-animal there's no people
I'm not sure why they decided to make
this the only one but it works okay
having Robin Hood as a fox is a clever
idea Little John is this gigantic bear
that works out pretty well and the
others lend their way to a lot of
creative jokes awesome
okay what's the story as Robin Hood goes
yes it follows it pretty close I'm a
good rob from the rich and gives to the
poor in order to defeat Prince John he's
in love with the lovely Maid Marian and
tries to win an archery contest but gets
caught in the process only to fight off
the men through many battles and many
fundraising adventures there's a lot of
acute Cena's that you'd expect from a
film like this but actually there are
some very entertaining action scenes
despite it being animated nights many of
these scenes are just as impressive as
the Errol Flynn version you can get away
with a lot more so it looks more
impressive Robin is pretty much your
very basic nice hero and may Marian is
very much a very typical native just a
nice little romance to soak up the kids
attention they stay in their basic roles
and I guess that worked out okay
they'll be ever noticed that Maid Marian
just disappears in the last third until
they get married let me at least have a
scene where he says goodbye to her
before he goes off to adventure or maybe
she's helping out with the scheme or
maybe she's watching him as he's running
away and I don't know she had so many
scenes before why just cut her out of
the third act
plenty the villain is Prince John and
he's a very fun comedic villain
especially when working off of his
psychic it's he's definitely a very femi
villain and a lot of times that leads to
a lot of very funny moments including
some great arguments with hiss which
makes them look very much like a married
but watching it again I actually found
the Sheriff of Nottingham was pretty
funny too he's just such a bastard in
the various ways he'll find to rip
people off even a blind person that is
evil what a nifty trick the climax is
one of the best in Disney history I know
that's weird seeing how they're all
cutesy animals but gets a really
suspenseful climax the first half of it
is done very much in silence a lot of
whispering a lot of quiet music a lot of
sneaking around and then once the cover
is blown it's just fast paced action
throughout the rest of it it's just
great because everywhere the main
character turns there's always something
else trying to get him he just cannot
get a break throughout this entire scene
you got arrows flying Adam axes henchmen
fire and it just keeps building higher
and higher throughout the castle it's a
really good set up overall Robin Hood is
a very good kids adventure though it's
not great and I don't know how many
great things are really in it but it is
very entertaining some parts drag but
when it doesn't it's a lot of fun kids
will definitely love it and I guess as
some of the adults might find themselves
getting sucked in it
[Music]
who doesn't love Winnie the Pooh hell
he's like one of the most innocent
things on the planet I think there's a
law actually forbidding people not to
like you
I know people who despise Mickey Mouse
but they can't bring themselves to
actually say they hate Winnie the Pooh
so what is it what is it that just makes
him so likable well I think a lot of it
has to deal with the fact that while he
is very optimistic he does make mistakes
and he does get in trouble
he's very naive but he's also very
pleasant and I think that makes it much
more interesting than someone like
Mickey Mouse he's still positive but
they're just much more of a character to
play with and it all started with this
one film The Many Adventures of Winnie
the Pooh these characters are so famous
now I don't even have to name kangaroo
Tigger owl rabbit piglet or the list
goes on the story is very loose in that
there's not that much of a flowing
narrative it's just sort of the life of
Pooh and his friends through the course
of a year maybe it's just all the
troubles circumstances and weird
situations they get in and how they
manage to live or get around it as a kid
I liked it fine but watching it now
years later actually it's a lot better
than I remember it eventually make a lot
of fourth-wall jokes using the book that
they're in and even sometimes talk about
the narrator but that's not the only
reason it's good there's just this sense
to it this atmosphere this real like
ability to this world and they've
created it's very laid back it's very
slow pace but at the same time these
characters are just so interesting and
so nice that you really enjoy spending
time with them you don't care if not
much is going on you could just have a
conversation with any one of these
people and you probably be very
satisfied I really like movies like that
they don't feel they have to stick to
the three-act structure and instead just
shoot the for a bit they just like
characters breathe and do whatever it is
they do and these characters are really
enjoyable man the situation's they get
in are really enjoyable we've got some
real creative scenarios with a windstorm
who trying to get more honey and of
course another trip is held Disney scene
with epilim son the songs are catchy and
clever the animation I think actually
matches the wound and style are going
for and like it's it there's just a real
heavy atmosphere to it especially like
the ending there's no big climax no
Jaycee no major discoveries it's just
Christopher Robin talking with his
imaginary friend and the inevitability
of the future ooh
when I'm away just doing nothing will
you come up here sometimes promise you
won't forget me oh I won't Christopher I
polish really kind of heavy stuff maybe
the Pooh is not often looked at as one
of the great Disney films but it is
looked at as one of the great Disney
characters and that's all the film is
just enjoying this character and all the
people that surround it it's clever it's
nice it's friendly I really enjoyed
watching it again in fact it's one of
the few Disney films where I like it
just as much as a kid as I do as an
adult it takes me right back to that
same place I enjoy I always love coming
back
[Applause]
[Music]
okay I'll just get it out of the way
there's a picture of a naked woman in
this movie Disney is full of pervs they
are done now let's talk about the movie
the rescuers sort of along the same
veins of the Aristocats are 101
Dalmatians in that there's not much
magic not much stellar animation and
mostly just cutesy animals looking
cutesy I don't think it's as bad as
something as the eristic and there is a
little bit more story and character to
it nothing much really stands out about
it it centers around a little girl who's
being held by this evil woman who wants
her to go inside this mine and get this
incredibly valuable diamond talk about
child labor laws well it turns out
there's a big group of mice called the
rescued Aid Society that go in and try
to help people in such circumstances
definitely a creative idea yes though I
guess like most people in the fee I
wonder what the heck a bunch of mice can
do in rescuing a bunch of people but I
guess that's the point of the film it's
no person too small yadda yadda yadda so
two mice named Bernard and Miss Bianca
go out to rescue her while also coming
across a bunch of colorful characters
doesn't remember a few things that stood
out like some of the bad guys actually
are entertaining like this crazy lady
who's holding the girl looks like
something out of a 1940's French
bordello not really bad 1940s friend
her reactions a lot of the time for
pretty fun she also has this blithering
sidekick but once in a while gets a good
line she also has these two alligators
that are probably one of the funniest
things of food aside from that it's just
more cuteness the little girl is
obnoxious I can't stand her she's like
one of the Olsen twins she's just
designed to look flashes really yeah
that little brat escaped again to start
yeah most of the movie is just filled
with other scenes that drag or overly
cutesy or don't really seem to have much
point I don't hate it I just don't
remember it doing very much for me
even as a kid I sort of remember being
bored by it again with the exception one
or two comedic seasons not really a fan
I'd probably say there's much better
Disney movie
[Music]
flex on the hound is another one of
those Disney movies that probably has
too many cutesy scenes in it but to its
credit it uses it much more to its
advantage the films about a little fox
who loses his mother and gets taken up
by an old lady she unfortunately though
happens to live right next door to a
hunter who has a dog two dogs actually a
one of them's a puppy trying to learn
how to hunt obviously you think these
two wouldn't get along but they seem to
hit it off pretty well as time goes on
their friendship becomes stronger
despite the fact that everybody's
telling them they're gonna be the worst
of enemies but they keep playing and
having fun and constantly get into
trouble it's not until the dog is taken
away for a long time and becomes a
professional hunting dog that he returns
and finds that their friendship can't be
the way they were through an accident
the Fox injures the dog's best friend
and the dog vows vengeance and on top of
that the woman finds she just can't hold
on to the Fox anymore and sets him free
in the wild this according to every
woman ever retard - is a big tearjerker
to see so the two are now enemies out
for blood and tried to see who will come
out on top a good setup for a story and
they do it pretty well but I have to
admit I felt like it could be stronger
like instead the best friend getting
injured why didn't he die I'm sorry it's
just this movie would have been a lot
more powerful if that dog died or how
about when the woman is laying the Fox
Go just having some instrumental music
or even have it silent instead of
playing whatever pop song was popular at
the time little tidbits like that really
keep me from loving this film but as a
Disney film it's pretty strong the big
scene after the climax is a very good
payoff and you can find yourself very
invested in it and like I said some of
the cutesy teens drag but I think it's
allowed to drag sort of in the same way
Bambi was allowed to drag you know
you're gonna get to the harder stuff
later I just wish it was a little
I don't know maybe it's the sick bastard
and me but I think this could have been
a little bit more adult but as is it's a
decent the songs aren't really that
memorable and I don't remember too many
of the side characters either but it's
the friendship between the two of them
that really holds up say it's definitely
worth your time taking a watch
[Music]
[Applause]
after Disney's death the studio didn't
have the stream of big hits that it used
to I mean it had a big hit every once in
a while but for the most part it never
quite hit the snow-white standards and
on top of that the films were just
taking longer and longer and longer to
make so if the film didn't really wow
audiences people start felt again Jude
and the film that many Disney fans call
the crowning achievement of failure is
the Black Cauldron how bad is it
well for a movie that had a ton of money
put into both the animation and the
advertising it failed to please
audiences and critics alike proving to
be a gigantic financial failure this
film did so bad that on its opening
weekend it lost to the Care Bears movie
you heard right a Disney film lost to
the Care Bears movie it was considered
the lowest point in Disney history so
Wow
this film must be really really bad
right well yeah despite the fact that
it's starting to grow sort of a cult
following he really doesn't hold up that
at least for my taste what's the story
well it's about this teenage boy who
wants to be a hero the only problem is
he's much more talk and much less due
and when I say talk I mean really talk I
mean this kid doesn't shut up Dolan
doesn't understand I'm not good for
boring young I should be doing heroic
deed for per day is this to be my life
pampering a pig
I'm a warrior and I know what they're
trying to do they're trying to make it
look like he's full of himself but an
innocent and then when he enters the
real world he's gonna discover things
about himself
bla bla bla bla but I'm sorry his voice
is annoying and on top of that his ego
is annoying
he barely does anything in this movie
thank you
thank you thank you all but without the
help of my Pig hen one here
he just praises himself and yeah I wanna
smack him well anyway he's looking after
this pig named Hedwig who has this very
distinct power of whenever he put her
head in a puddle of water she can see
the future isn't that weird well
apparently there's this evil demon known
as the Horned King and he wants
possession of the pig so he can take her
and look into the future to see if she
can lead into the Black Cauldron
what's the Black Cauldron apparently
it's a device that can bring people back
from the dead and create an invincible
arm along the way he comes across a
princess yeah imagine a princess into
Disney and I know I go on and on about
Princess Rance but really there is
absolutely no point to having her be a
princess in this movie even by Disney
standard she doesn't do when do you
think princess see she doesn't wear
fancy dresses she doesn't give orders
she doesn't I don't know sing we don't
even see her kingdom
we don't even see her castle we don't
see anything that Disney loves to market
when it comes to princesses all she's
got going for her is the name so really
there was no reason for it there's also
this really annoying comic relief that's
sort of like a mix between oatmeal and a
hairball yeah you thought Jar Jar Binks
voice was annoying get a load of this
smacking wagons poor campaign yeah
between these two characters voices I
want to strangle this film even the
music by the great Elmer Bernstein
all I hear throughout the entire thing
is ghostbusters listen
[Music]
tell me that doesn't sound like the Zul
theme okay so for all my bitching and
moaning is this really one of the worst
Disney films of all time I don't know if
I can go that far I mean it is annoying
but there is some creativity to the
animation oh not much that's frustrating
as a Kenda never gets to a point where
it says anything bad I mean mechanically
bad messages or morals or anything it's
just our bland and forgettable like a
lot of Disney films that were coming out
of that time it's not the worst but it's
definitely one of our ones but like I
said the films really starting to grow
in fans and I find more and more people
actually sort of have this secret light
for it so maybe there is something there
that can grab a certain group of people
but it's certainly been gramby and it's
certainly been grabbed a lot of
audiences at the time Black Cauldron is
often called one of Disney's biggest
families I think it's just kind of a bad
not the worst but I probably steal
[Music]
Great Mouse Detective
this is actually one of the first Disney
films I ever saw in theatres and when
you're a little kid watching the magic
of Disney on the big screen this is
exactly what you want to open up that
scary as far
well after that movie it's actually much
more tape at least not quite as creepy
the movie is about a little girl trying
to get her father back she comes across
a mouse named Dawson and they both come
across a mouse named basil of Baker
Street
who's the rodent equivalent of Sherlock
Holmes in fact he actually lives in
Sherlock Holmes house they're off to not
only find the little girl's father but
also stop an evil villain named Ratigan
played by Vincent Price his plan is to
have her father make a robotic Queen so
that he can replace her at some sort of
ceremony where the robotic Queen with
that named him the ruler
that was for kids mice are running
around they can talk you can get away
with this I guess and anyway that's
not the focus of the focus of the movie
is actually what it should be the hero
and the villain the hero in this movie
is great he's this egotistical but still
very likable character he's energized
he's kooky he's tenacious he's a jerk
sometimes but he's got a good heart
it's all that great stuff you love in a
hero and on top of that he's smart as
hell it's actually one of those few
Disney films where you admire how
intelligent the main character is I mean
from beginning to end you actually want
to be smarter watching him and then of
course there's the villain voiced by
Vincent Price what more do I have to say
it's Vincent Price and he is loving
every minute of it he's egotistical he's
selfish he sings he prances around he
giggles he just enjoys being nasty so
much that it's hard not to enjoy it
along with them the two play off each
other brilliantly it's just these two
gigantic brilliant egos working off I
usually find them with a celebrity boys
even the really good ones you can often
sort of feel them in the recording like
yeah acting but you know they're acting
you can see them saying their lines into
the microphone with Vincent Price I
never got that he's just right there
in the role its ratting you watch this
movie again and tell me if you can
really disconnect the recording of
Vincent Price with the animation of the
character they're just flawless oh by
the way better
one would hardly recognizing they meld
together perfectly no one on the subject
of the animation that's pretty good too
I think this is actually the first time
they started using computer graphics and
an animated and speaking of that it
makes for a break - there's a giant
fight scene in the clock tower it's
among one of Disney's mess the angles
are great the music builds the pacing is
wonderful and we see Radigan finally
show his true colors in fact it gets
pretty violent I mean there's no blood
or anything but there might as well be
the sound effects and everything really
make it look like it hurts but hey when
you're a little kid that just sucks you
in even for the Great Mouse Detective is
really smart really delightful and
really fun it is so your typical little
mouse adventure where they just look at
the big world and so create their own
little world and you laugh and giggle at
it but like I said what sets it apart
from the other ones is the main
character and the main villain there's
just a ton of fun to watch I think it's
one that often sneaks under the radar
for most Disney fans but it's definitely
worth checking out find it on DVD and
discover for yourself
[Music]
you
okay so in all honesty it's a little
hard to talk about Oliver and company
without talking about another animated
film that came out the exact same
weekend the Land Before Time when I was
a kid
Oliver and company was the movie I
wanted to see I heard the Billy Joel
songs I saw the animation I saw the cool
dogs I saw New York it just looked like
an awesome but it was sold out at the
time and my folks could only get tickets
to the Land Before Time okay I guess I
can see that in the Land Before Time as
most of you know was a really great film
the animation was great the story was
great it was very disney-esque but we're
not reviewing that we're reviewing
Oliver and company the film I really
wanted to see is a little kid so next
week we got our tickets set on down and
after land before time this was really
underwhelming I know it's weird saying
that even as I'm an adult talking about
this and reviewing it again but the
reason I bring it up is because the land
before time was much more like a Disney
film than Oliver and company was it did
a much better job teaching life lessons
with really heavy scenes and well really
memorable characters Oliver and company
definitely seemed like a marketing tool
even as a kid I sort of felt manipulated
by it
in fact I actually remember enjoying the
toys much more than I remember enjoying
the movie yeah I had a Cheech Marin dog
what about it anyway let's get to the
actual story it's the basic Oliver Twist
story except with animals and it doesn't
take place in the time of Charles
Dickens it takes place in modern-day New
York City here that's catchy drawn style
actually has a little bit more of a hole
it sort of looks like an etching you see
maybe in a New York store a fine art
store something like that in this
version Oliver is the boy he's a kitten
and Dodger isn't a boy either he's a dog
but not just a dog a grown-up dog voiced
by Billy Joel in terms of the Oliver's
story I really find that distracting I
liked how Dodger and Oliver's are a had
a connection how they were sort of the
same age
blah-blah-blah-blah if I'm gonna connect
this to the original Oliver's story I'm
gonna be really disappointed there's
really no point in setting in a
modern-day or
New York or with animals so let's just
ignore that for now look at the story as
it is Oliver meets up with a bunch of
tough dogs were owned by this bum points
by Dom DeLuise he does dealings with
this gangster but not because he wants
to or because he just got himself in the
bad situation much like Oliver Twist
though Oliver finds himself in the hands
of a much nicer family and is constantly
flip-flopping back and forth throughout
the entire film the nice family has a
dog voice my Bette Midler and of course
she gets a song eventually it ends up in
this kind of complicated story about
kidnapping the little girl and now
Oliver and the gang have to go save her
I guess it leads to kind of a neat
climax and actually one of the best
villain deaths ever I literally remember
nothing about this villain except how he
died watch this that is awesome
aside from that the movie only has a few
things to offer one is that goddamn
catchy song and it is catchy you'll be
humming it all day once you watch this
review
I don't think the other songs are very
catchy I think they just had this one
big hit and they just exploited it like
mad
I do remember Cheech Marin as the
Chihuahua yeah he gets a funny line
every once in a while it's funny
thinking he'd come back as a hyena a few
years later and actually I really do
like the way they portray New York after
finally having been there I gotta say
it's pretty close to accurate it's big
but it's tight there's a lot of attitude
but there's a lot a character too from
an animation point of view the down
spot-on aside from that it's
surprisingly forgettable I don't
remember too many of the characters I'm
like I said the songs don't really leave
you humming much except for the one yeah
for Disney to do a version of Oliver and
I expected a lot more than this at least
for it to make a bigger impact but again
it's not awful it's just strange
thinking that the non Disney film at the
time was turning out the much better
Disney product if you're an animal
person
maybe you'll get into some of the cute
eNOS of it but aside from that it's
nothing to scream about well let's face
it this was just the film to tide us
over before the next gigantic it
you
[Music]
after the disappointment of the Black
Cauldron Disney suddenly got on this
huge King not only were they gonna turn
out better products but they were gonna
turn him out fast the films went from
coming out every five to seven to even
10 years to suddenly every year and the
film that sparked the Disney golden era
a revolutionary film that started hit
after hit after hit again The Little
Mermaid yeah you all know it you've all
seen it and now we're gonna talk about
it is there any point in comparing it to
the Hans Christian Andersen story I mean
we all know she doesn't die at the end
Disney wouldn't do that if I helped I
think they couldn't do that so much like
Oliver and company let's just keep it to
the content ethics this is the first
film in a long time where the animation
was actually looking like Disney
animation again this was the return to
the fairy tale the smooth lines the nice
songs the beautiful backgrounds all the
stuff that started with Snow White and
most people think of when they hear the
word Disney the story is about Ariel a
16 year old girl who's obsessed with
being on dry land
her father forbids it but then she falls
in love with a handsome prince after
saving his life she decides that she
absolutely wants to become human so that
she can be with him so she sells her
voice to Ursula the sea witch and gets
herself a pair of legs the only downside
is she can't tell the prince who she is
which means she has to start from
scratch in order to win him over of
course while the sea witch is plotting
her way to get control of the underworld
the feedback I get from this movie is
fascinating and not actually from guys
believe or not but from women I find the
either love or hate this movie and all
of it centers around the main character
Ariel but we'll get to that in a second
let's look at the good stuff the music
you know it in and out it's Alan
Menken's songs and man are they
memorable catchy as hell they're bouncy
they're fun they're slow there were
diabolical he gets the tone just like
the comic relief supply there's a fun
Tibbits with the crab yeah Buddy Hackett
is the seagull there's a crazy-ass Chef
voiced by odo it's pretty good the
animation top-notch this is the
animation people wanted to see from
Disney for a while and men did it blow
people away it still blows me away
watching it today looking at these
angles look at the colors everything it
just pops the villain is great what's
like Ratigan she just so enjoys what
she's doing although it's much more of a
revenge betta it is just to be even so
maybe her plot is a little bit more
motivation and I like the fact this was
the first Disney film where the couple
actually had to build their romance from
some way they didn't just meet and
suddenly love each other well okay they
meet and they love each other but at the
same time they have to meet and they
have to work at it again it's not like
Snow White where they meet and they get
married or Sleeping Beauty where they
need they say if suddenly they're in
love there is some development here even
though it did take what three days well
okay the Disney verse that was a long
time but let's get to what most women
either love or hate The Little Mermaid
herself
okay so what's bad about her she is
white even there are nice songs we get
down to it is just very pretty white she
certainly has all the typical
sixteen-year-old cliches like hating her
father talking about boys wanting to
throw her life away for them so let's be
honest that's kind of typical
maybe that's why some women ate it I
mean I guess Bella's living out a lot of
girls fantasies too but doesn't
necessarily mean her character well she
definitely has a passion and a drive
assets are a part for a lot of the other
Disney women she's a hopeless romantic
but she's also determined what she wants
something she'll go to whatever lengths
it takes to get it so for the most part
I thought a lot of the backlash about
the character was just sort of ending
but then I watched Lindsey's review and
she brought this she doesn't really
change she doesn't learn anything
Arielle wants something there are
obstacles she gets what she wants the
end yeah that's so really good despite
her causing all this trouble she still
gets exactly what she wants she whines
and complains and in the end she's
rewarded for it but you could make a
very slim argument that once they have
her and she's apologizing that she has
acknowledged she made a mistake and that
admittedly she should have done
[Music]
but the scene is two seconds long and
then although she gets her way anyway at
the end so it doesn't really matter yes
there are some major character flaws
with her so why can't I still enjoy her
well
horrible to say I actually really like
it when she can't talk yeah I know make
whatever we've been shooting speech joke
you want but that's not the reason I
like it I like it because her curiosity
comes out in full bloom
she isn't complaining here she's
enjoying she's in heaven seeing all
these new things
she's a wanderer she's an explorer she
likes discovering things and no where
does that come out clearer in just the
simple expressions and the great
animation here even her songs which are
sing complaining I guess actually really
do show how she feels about a situation
then is very passionate so I guess
that's what a lot of people really do
get behind it so yeah deconstructing
childhoods aside how does this bill hold
s it has the ethical flaws that a lot of
people say or just ethical laws and
Disney films in general you know just
meeting a person a day wanting to Miriam
not always dealing with the consequences
of your actions but the stuff that's
good is really friggin good the music
like I said outstanding some of the best
the animation stealth the comic relief
memorable the villain awesome even the
father character a character that
usually gets tossed aside in most disney
movies is actually pretty well developed
and our main characters despite their
flaws still have a lot of things you can
write about personally I still really
enjoyed it has its issues but the good
stuff is just too damn good and this
would only be the first monster hit that
would set
[Music]
so after the Great Mouse Detective we
all know the release of the Disney films
after him right Little Mermaid Beauty
and the beasts Aladdin Lion King and so
forth rah between Little Mermaid and
Beauty and the Beast there was actually
another anime and film that everybody
seems to gloss over the rescuers down
under even today when I bring up the
rescuers down under everybody says oh
the little girl in the cave with a skull
and diamond right no no why does
everyone always remember the bland
forgettable one how ironic is that
I'll admit out of all the Disney films
to give a sequel it's kind of weird that
they did the rescuers but you know what
they put their damnest into this movie
this is one of the best-looking Disney
adventures that has ever come out of the
studio and I have no idea why it
continues to get the shaft alright so
what's the story we have a little boy in
Australia who of course does man
Australian accent who comes across a
giant golden eagle last one alive he
frees it from a trap than a poacher
played by George Scott captures him and
tries to force him to tell him the
location of the burger this gets
attention all the way from across the
world and leads to New York where
Bernard and Miss Bianca voiced again by
Bob Newhart Najah Joe Gabor are
requested to go down there and say
instead of using all the bird from the
last movie we instead this time gift
will burn get it over and we'll burn it
works but it works even better when you
have the comedic genius of John Candy
supplying points may I just say on page
seniorita to you may I
this is just another great passionate
role that he gets into and he's
wonderful as always
what miss Bianca doesn't know is that
Bernard is trying to propose to her all
throughout the movie and yet he
constantly keeps getting distracted by
this other Mouse who's trying to put the
poison you really feel for this guy all
he wants to do is pop the question and
some crap keeps happening to interrupt
him it's more of a block than The
Legend of Zelda cartoon okay so as you
can hear the story is nothing fantastic
it's just sort of your basic everyday
adventure with little mice kind of like
the first one except it's done a million
bajillion gajillion times better like
the scene where the boy
fries the eagle he could just free her
and then she just takes him back to the
net right it take a minute to do but
that we get an intense fall
off a mountain
flying through the sky skating on a
river jumping off a waterfall holy
just watch some of this animation
[Music]
yeah this is what you're missing folks
how come nobody's looking at this on top
of that it's a good adventure it's got
some great action scenes the villain is
great hey it's George Z Scott the main
characters are likable the backgrounds
are unbelievable the animation as I said
before is spectacular it's fun it's
funny it's just a great family adventure
thing there was even a short before with
Mickey Mouse called The Prince and the
pauper and you know what that's also
underrated it's a really good short
check it out I'm sure it's on DVD
somewhere so okay why is it this movie
gets so overlooked well I got two
theories one is that on the first
weekend the film didn't open very strong
so Disney immediately pulled all
advertisement so the reason you've
probably never heard of it is because
you weren't allowed to hear of it
advertising and publicity after that was
kept very tight but I think the other
reason it doesn't do so hot is because
it doesn't have any the typical Disney
form it's not a fairy tale there's no
song there's no strong ethics or morals
and it doesn't have any of the extremely
cute fuzzy animals that they want to
market I mean the rescuers are cute I
guess but it's no flounder but so what
it's not supposed to be any of those
things it's just supposed to be a really
good adventure film and not only is it
good it's incredibly good do we look at
films like Raiders of the Lost Ark or
Terminator 2 as bad simply cuz they're
not as good as something like Citizen
Kane
no they still celebrate it there's still
the top of their class so how come this
one doesn't get any more folks we gotta
turn this around we have to increase the
DVD sales of this movie because you know
what more people deserve to see it yeah
it's a family action flick but it's a
phenomenal family action taking a
subject material that really had little
going for it and turning it into a
friggin experience check it out folks
you won't regret
[Music]
okay so a lot of you know that my
favorite animated Disney film is
Fantasia of course but if I had to
choose one that told a coherent story
from beginning to end cashing in on the
Disney fairy tale aspect then that would
definitely have to be Beauty and the
Beast
why because everything is done perfect
the main character is perfect the
villain is perfect the romance is
perfect the songs are perfect even the
design of the castle look at that thing
it's like something out of The Haunting
it's just friggin incredible but let's
start at the beginning we get a cleverly
narrated backstory through stained glass
windows telling us the tale about how
the prince who had little to no love in
his heart gets turned into a beast by a
sorcerer after treating her so cruel he
was given a magic grow as they're slowly
withering away if he can learn how to
fall in love and be loved in return
he'll go back to human thus we enter
Belle
she's the oddball of the neighborhood
because she's hot as hell but she
doesn't want it she doesn't hang out
with other women fawning over men he
just reads her books and doesn't bother
anybody which of course confuses a very
gossipy town that is except for Gaston
in any other movie he'd probably be the
hero but here he's the good-looking
villain who has much more muscle than
brains
he thinks that because he's the
best-looking man in town and those the
best-looking woman in town
naturally they should get married he's
in that great illogic Nevel turns him
down he swears to get his bride well
that's going on Belle's father leaves
town and comes across a net chained to
castle where the Beast lives but the
Beast says he's trespassing and throws
him in the dungeon where Belle finds him
later she exchanges her life for his and
he lets him go though the Beast sees
this as an opportunity to finally fall
in love he's not very social in fact
he's downright beastly I thought I told
you to come down for dinner
I'll break down the door but through the
help of some very well chosen and very
well paced events the two actually do
start to fall in love with each other
they both slowly start to let down their
defenses and stoop to see the good which
of course leads to romance and this
action bloodshed magic all that good
stuff people fell in love with this
movie in fact at the time it was the
only anime film to be nominated for Best
Picture that was unheard of so why did
it hit a chord with so many people well
first of all it goes back to the Disney
roots but follows all the way through
it's a fairy tale and it knows them and
it totally engulfs itself in it but as
fairy tales go there's a few twists this
time the couple actually has to take
their time to fall in love with each
other they don't just meet and suddenly
they're meant for one another and the
movie is actually very clever at never
saying how long they're together it
could be weeks it could be months so
that way you're allowed to draw your own
conclusions
the villain is a much more realistic
villain he doesn't start off just evil
and bad he's actually the town hero but
as he fails to get his way for longer
and longer he turns to more desperate
measures
which leads to one of the more obvious
but still pretty poignant lines he's no
monster guest on you are and then you
got Belle Belle is one of the best
animated characters ever she looks good
but she doesn't show off she's kind
though she has her limit people mock her
though she could really care less and
she's just off doing her own thing not
giving a what anybody says on top
of it she's looking for something a
little more specific than most Disney
female leads and that's something
greater than herself something grand
something spectacular something that she
can barely comprehend
that's actually pretty deep for a kid's
film it's much better than saying I want
a prince or feed or whatever and it also
works out because it turns out what
she's searching for is in the very last
place you would ever look now there is
an argument that maybe Belle is too
perfect that she's not really that
complex because she doesn't have many
to flaws and I'd be lying if I said I
didn't see that she's much more of a
role model the kind of person we want to
be as opposed to the kind of people we
encounter know if it's still a good role
model and the character still seems
existent see much my problem
I don't really see the downside and
liking her it's that belief in the best
of humanity so for me I really enjoy her
she's kind smart it just does her own
thing I should also talk about the beast
- I love the way this thing is designed
whenever I heard the story of Beauty and
the Beast before this movie came out
this is pretty much what I imagined the
beast looked like very big very werewolf
light so I thought he was awesome I
guess if I had to pick one problem with
the movie it would be the design of the
human version of the Beast the animators
say that no matter what they put there
the people would have been happy because
well they fell in love with the Beast
and not this guy I think that's kind of
true but I don't know if you put in Erik
or a ladder there is something I don't
think anyone would complain and plus
people fell in love with the Beast
because you called him beast what's his
real name
did she just keep calling him Beast
after he transformed no it's a nitpick
do I really have to explain what else is
good about this movie you all know the
songs you all know how great the
animation is you all remember these
characters it's just a flawless film as
I get older and older it only gets
better and better
it's the pure Disney fairy tale done to
the absolute best I'd say go see it but
let's face it you already have
[Music]
when I was a kid Aladdin was my favorite
Disney movie I felt like even though I
liked Little Mermaid and Beauty and the
Beast this was the first Disney movie
for boys it had action it had sword
fights and head Lama it had flying
around on magic carpets it had monsters
it had comedy it had a lot of adult
jokes that I actually sort of understood
it had kick-ass songs it was just
awesome but I will admit as I get older
that novelty seems to wear off a bit
unlike Beauty and the Beast that gets
better and better as I get older I do
see more and more of the flaws of
Aladdin
okay well let's look at the story
Aladdin is a thief trying to get by in
the streets he comes across a princess
named Jasmine who's trying to get away
from the palace to make a life for her
own but he gets captured by a sorcerer
named Jafar and gets manipulated into
searching for a magic lamp here he comes
across a flying carpet and of course the
genie do I even need to say who poised
him hello Aladdin nice to have you on
the show can we call you out or maybe
just did how about lattes so he goes
back to town using one of his wishes to
turn himself into a prince
this allows him the possibility to marry
the princess but Jafar won't let it
happen he tries to kill Aladdin and take
the lamp away so he can use the genie
for his own diabolical powers begin your
sword fight giant monsters action comedy
all that good stuff so what is it about
Aladdin that does or doesn't well a lot
of the time it's sort of the same thing
Aladdin is very modern even Agrabah
looks much more like Vegas than a dozen
Arabian City of course Robin Williams
jokes well funny all come from a way
that current people talk and even movies
that haven't been made by this time
period if I didn't even know what movies
were back then so there's a lot of
breaking the fourth wall jokes and of
course a lot of modern-day talk
dude well most of it aladdin and Jasmine
though they don't quote as many movie
stars as Williams does still seem out of
their time period - he seemed more like
Gen Xers than they knew the product of
an Arabian village Jafar is pretty cool
and the Sultan is enjoyably stupid but
most of it doesn't seem to take place
once upon a time but more around the
time that maybe shrek lives in fact yeah
she probably stole a lot from this movie
didn't they so does that make a light
him bad necessarily if anything it makes
it unique it's a very different take
that Disney was trying to do and
apparently it really paid off the jokes
Robin Williams makes is funny and
despite the fact that it doesn't look
like Arabia it still looks great the
colors in this movie are just wonderful
as well as the lighting on top of that
what I think is really important is that
aladdin and Jasmine do have chemistry
yeah I know it's another three day
romance and then suddenly they get
married but you know what you believe
they're in love they do have
conversations that you talk about their
problems that they do try to help each
other out
okay it's not Beauty the bees but they
works okay
the songs are still awesome it's still
Alan Menken and it's still those
incredibly catchy beats at times some of
the modern talking get a little annoying
like when Aladdin tries to act cool or
Gilbert Godfried yells some more but I
think it still has the same Disney heart
and it is very entertaining so while I
don't like it as much as I did when I
was a kid I still do like it there's
still a lot of things to admire a lot of
things to laugh at and a lot of things
to hop
as long as you know what you're getting
yourself into chances are you'll have a
pretty good time
[Music]
and now we come to the big The Lion King
the highest-grossing 2d animated film of
all time when this movie came out every
kid was nuts we were humming all the
songs we were reenacting all the scenes
we were talking about all the characters
it was just a gigantic flick so is it
bad to say I think it's kind of
overrated well I don't think it's bad I
don't think it's the strongest of
Disney's works either I don't even know
if I necessarily put it in the top five
but that doesn't mean there aren't some
very impressive things about it or that
the film as a whole doesn't work well
here let's start from the beginning we
start with the birth of the new Prince
and do I even need to tell you how they
celebrate this
[Music]
so young Simba is shown around by King
Mufasa how to rule as a good king
but his uncle Scar is angry because he
was next in line to be killed so he
constantly tries to set traps with the
hyenas to kill him off but Mufasa is
always there to save them so there's
only one logical choice kill Mufasa this
leads to a very intense and very well
done chasey with a bunch of wildebeest
scar seize this opportunity and throws
him off a cliff Simba thinking that he
started the Stampede feels incredibly
guilty and scar advises him to run away
why he doesn't just kill him right there
I don't know but simple goes into exile
and comes across a team known as Timon
and Pumbaa they tell him that's okay to
run away from your problems and start a
new life over and that's exactly what he
does he spends most of his years growing
up with the two and decides never to go
back that is until his old childhood
friend shows up and tells him that
things are terrible back at home and
since he is the rightful king he's the
only one that can go back and make
things better
the Simba doubts himself thinking he
still killed his father until he gets a
vision in the sky his father says nut up
and Simba decides to go back home and
fight his own and you know the drill big
climax comic relief get some laughs and
then the final showdown between the two
of them okay so what problems do I have
with a story that actually seems almost
adult and that is stole from the most
famous of a dumb Plains well let's get
to my biggest problem the message
actually the message I really like and I
think it's a very adult message I
especially like it when he talks to
Rafiki about it oh but the way I see it
you can either run from it for learn
from now that's really clever and I'm
totally behind that what I'm not behind
is that when he does go back to face his
fears his fears start to win and
everything he was taught before suddenly
is working against him nobody even gets
behind him nobody's standing up for him
that is until it turns out he didn't
commit the crime that he thought he did
so I guess the moral of the story is
never take responsibility for what
you've done because nobody will be
behind you unless it turns out you
didn't really do it yeah how is this
confronting his past it's a past that
never happened so it doesn't matter and
even when he thought it did happen the
movie didn't support him almost as it
film was saying if he did accidentally
kill his father he deserves to die look
nobody's on his side until he comes out
and says haha wasn't me and I'm sorry
that's a serious flaw if you think it's
something that just might over analyzing
it don't mind thought oh no I was
thinking of this as a kid too
this film didn't teach me to come
forward with my mistakes and to take the
responsibility for it
it taught me to convince people that I
didn't do the mistake because that way
I'll have a happy ending okay so good
intention gets totally botched what else
don't I like well the songs yeah yeah I
know but I'm sorry I don't like these
songs well I take it back be prepared is
awesome circle of life is good so I
think a lotta is more Hans Zimmer's
orchestrations can you feel the love
tonight hate it I can't wait to be king
hated Hakuna Matata
holy balls I hate this song I hated it
when it first came out I was bobble by
the fact that everybody was actually
singing this it's annoying while I was
constantly humming be prepared at school
all the other kids were constantly
singing Hakuna Matata
I'm so on top of that big shock I think
Matthew Broderick is pretty bland
Jonathan Taylor Thomas is a little bit
too but to be fair he's a kid and he
really does sell those crime scenes the
villain well good is a little too
simplistic I don't know he seems so
smart and intelligent but then when he
takes over he seems like a little child
that just sucks out all the dignity and
likability that you have for him it's
like if Maleficent after she got her way
suddenly started going me
and there's also details like how did
the water come flowing back after Simba
took over why did the weather get better
why is it suddenly green but that's
Disney logic I can't complain it hard
about it so ok I fished about the movie
long enough what do I like about it well
it's big
I mean friggin big if you can see this
movie on the big screen see it when
scars paw comes down for the first time
it's just massive
I actually remember somebody in the
audience going whoa on top of that the
characters are great James Earl Jones is
Mufasa is a great leader Jeremy Irons is
over the top
a villain but he's still pretty
enjoyable the hyenas are funny Ron
Atkinson has a few good puns here and
there I'm not a huge fan of Timon and
Pumbaa but my stomach them okay I get a
laugh everyone and even though the
message is sort of botched I like the
message it's trying to get across so
like I said what makes this film good is
just the size of it and it doesn't just
come from the animation it does come
from the story it's a big story like I
said it's basically a kid version of
Hamlet but they don't sugarcoat it that
much they don't pull a Bambi's mom where
she dies off-screen no no you see the
body that was a big thing for kids back
then to have a death scene right in the
middle of a big action-packed moment was
pretty unexpected for Disney at least at
that time so overall I do like it
I do wish some of the other Disney films
got more attention and made more money
but that doesn't mean the original film
is bad it's a big film with a pretty big
story and a pretty big message I just
have my own personal issues it's a movie
I was glad to see several times in the
theatres and chances are when they
rerelease it again I'll go and check it
out a few more
[Music]
so Disney was producing some of the
biggest hits the world has ever seen The
Little Mermaid a lot of people saw
Beauty and the Beast most people saw
Aladdin everybody saw and The Lion King
was the highest-grossing animated film
at that time what could possibly go
wrong for Disney yeah
yes Pocahontas seems to be that snowball
that started the avalanche of downward
spiraling Disney animated films it
wasn't a big critical disappointment or
even that big of financial
disappointment but nobody praised it
like they praised the other Disney films
especially the general public not just
adults but even kids found the whole
idea of telling the story of the Indian
princess to be well not that interesting
and the 2d Disney animated films would
never quite hit the record-breaking
numbers that they did with Lion King
Aladdin and so forth after this came out
so is it as bad as everybody made it out
to be well let's look at the good stuff
first of all you gotta give Disney
credit for trying something pretty
different with this I mean for a company
that mostly based its animated films on
fairy tales and pop cultural references
this was a very different turn even the
look of the film is different the soft
smooth lines are not really as prominent
and look even the eyes have really
shrunken down the characters don't look
like the typical Barbie and Ken's
stereotypes that you get in most Disney
films but I think people kind of miss
that I think there's just something so
jarring when your last human characters
look like this and then suddenly they
look like this but he amor don't look
his mind if there's a more adult story
and that is not at all what this is I'm
not even gonna try and talk about the
history aspect of this cuz trust me
there's no point they made most of it up
but that wouldn't matter as much if it
was done well but pretty much what we
have is the typical greedy white guy
comes to take over the native land a
story that adults and especially kids
have heard over and over and over in
after-school specials are they right
yeah but can you find a new way of
telling it I think a lot of us don't see
the purpose in watching a story if we
already know exactly what's gonna happen
and pretty much how you're going to tell
it okay let's get to the technicals here
our main lead is Pocahontas she's strong
free spirited and dull as a rock
yeah I'm sorry she's just not that
interesting I mean I know she does
things that the other princesses don't
do but her actions are one thing her
personality is something different and
she's not bad she's just not that fun to
watch the only person to be more boring
as John Smith played by Mel Gibson him
and his crew come across the Native
Americans and decide they want to take
over their land which leads to teaching
the white idiots a new point of view
constant misunderstandings that of
course result in capture and death and
an evil bad guy who refuses to listen
and just once gold gold gold it's your
classic who's the sandwich story which
like I said wouldn't be bad if they
could do something new with it and for
those thinking that this was one of the
first films to try it it's not like I
said this stuff was in countless
after-school specials and TV shows and
all sorts of things geared towards kids
so this was really nothing that
unexpected one of the biggest complaints
at the time is that the animals don't
talk and at first I kind of liked it I
like a little mind silent school stuff
where you don't hear them talk and it's
all on the expressions but then when you
really think about it this is a film
about communicating with nature why
don't the animals talk if there's any
Disney movie where it actually makes
sense to hear the animal speak this is
it but if they don't want to make them
talk that's fine
maybe they're communicating with nature
in another way like you know talking to
the trees wait a minute the trees can
talk but the animals can't what sense
does that make
yeah I don't get it either as a pre
silly choice now wait a minute didn't I
say I was gonna talk about the good
things in this movie cuz there are a few
most of us know colors of the wind and
even though it's preachy it's still a
pretty decent song I really like savages
even though the lyrics at times are a
little goofy another thing that's really
cool about this movie is the colors they
look great you sort of don't even see
the lines the colors just sort of take
them over whoever did the artistic
design really knew what they were doing
and once in a while you get some cute
counter
from the little animal friends but aside
from that there's not much to talk about
he's it really awful I suppose not any
it's not doing anything god-awful apart
from you know rewriting history
but hey history already did that and
it's Disney you expect them to take
horrifying stories and change them
around to have a happy ending but
Pocahontas biggest crime is that it's
dull and predictable now that Disney has
always been unpredictable but it's
always been entertaining focus is just a
snorefest apart from looking at it
there's really not that much to have fun
with we already know what the lessons
gonna be we already know the characters
are gonna discover we already know their
flaws their strengths their weaknesses
we already know who's gonna die we
already know who's gonna live so why are
we watching it well a lot of people
didn't like I said this was the first
film to start the sort of animated
Disney town even though they'd still
have some hits after it none of them
would ever reach the golden age that
Disney hit a few years ago so well it's
not awful I can see why it started this
downward spiral Disney would need to
have a truly ingenious idea for their
next film to pull him out of it
the result well join me in the next one
[Music]
well if Disney really wanted to bounce
back from some of the disappointment
brought by Pocahontas Hunchback and
nurtured um was probably not the best
way to go a story is well known and
famously dark and twisted as hunchback
is probably not the best way to get a
general audience coming back to you but
I'm sure by the time polka eyes was done
hunchback was already half done and he
just had to go with what you got and for
what they got honestly I really love it
but that's a personal preference to be
very straightforward the film does in
fact have a lot flaws as you would
probably assume it would hunchback is
probably the last movie you would want
to tell as a Disney family film the
original story by Victor Hugo was about
the corruption of church and the overuse
of power that it had here it's mostly
told as an ugly duckling story and while
that's done well as parts that you feel
what kind of horse God will get to know
let's start with the story essence in
many respects it's very similar to the
book a deformed Hunchback lives in the
bell tower of Notre Dom he's looked
after by a man named Frollo in this
version he's portrayed as a judge in the
original he was a priest the hunchback
named Quasimodo just wants to go out
into the streets and be accepted like
anyone else and during the festival
fools which is a celebration of the
gypsies he gets his chance and not only
is he accepted but he's actually
celebrated people love how strange he
looks and start having fun with him now
in the original he accidentally commits
some sir crime is then punished for it
to which the Gypsy Esmeralda pops up and
tries to give him water in this version
he doesn't commit a crime the crowd just
suddenly turns on him a sporadically
actually - which again as Marella goes
up to save it but it turns out Farlow
has the hots for her and wants to do
everything in his power together again
in the original she
first of a crime he or she's accused of
witchcraft which is really nothing more
than the parlor tricks
so between Frollo wanting her Quasimodo
wanting her and hey did I mention
there's a third guy named Phoebus who
also is wanting her it's a pretty
complicated love square many other
elements of the original stories they're
like Quasimodo saving her sanctuary
people trying to break into Notre Dom
but it's sort of told out of order it
works here though Lani gives us all the
famous scenes that we love to watch so
wait this Hunchback falls flat
well I don't want to say fall flat but
there are times during the story where
it feels a little forced
like the animators really want to tell
certain parts of the story but then
other times they put it in because they
probably got a lot of notes about it
for example the romance between
Esmerelda and Phoebus is not very
interesting we just saw a crack
one-liners at each other but to be fair
they do set aside time in the story for
them to fall in love it's not like they
just meet and boom they're together
also the explanation of the gipsies
especially for a kid I think it's really
complicated if you had no idea what a
gypsy is this will probably confuse you
more they're said to be all thieves and
yet there's a festival celebrating them
furlough fouls to destroy them all and
yet he shows up to the festival
Esmerelda says that they're not all
really thieves but then they find their
giant fortress where they stole all
their I guess you could argue that
sort of shows the complications of the
Gypsy culture but I don't know I think
it would just confuse kids okay let's
talk about the guards god I friggin hate
these things number one how dare you
make Jason Alexander not funny shame on
you number two the moral of the story is
not to judge people by how they look and
yet that's constantly what they're doing
with the big mouth I get a bit of a
mixed message third as annoying as they
are I would give the movie credit if
they were imaginary and you know what at
first it looks like they are they don't
just turn back to stone there's a scene
where they have a whole musical number
and appears that all the stuff they were
showing before wasn't real like it was
all in Quasimodo's mind that's a great
idea I would honestly tolerate them if
this was the thought going into it that
Quasimodo was just imagining them what a
great but also tragic way to get your
comic
we fit but in the end nope they're real
they're fighting off the guards they're
helping him save the day
there's no way Quasimodo could imagine
this they just come to life I won't
question how it's Disney magic but come
on you can make these guys a lot less
obnoxious okay so that's all my bad
stuff let's talk about the good stuff
because honestly there's a lot let's
talk about what everybody remembers the
film Oh
Frollo is such a badass awesome villain
he does all the best early things they
allowed the other Disney villains to but
they actually make him complex too he
tries to convince himself a he's a
soldier for God and yet he's constantly
doing horrible things but he tries to
justify it every single time I love it
that's a great character voici mono is
also very likable that's Tom halls the
guy who did Amadeus doing the voice
there's such a kindness to us such a
softness and even though his singing
voice isn't technically been great
there's still so much heart and passion
put into it that you don't care it
sounds wonderful
[Applause]
songs are very different for the most
part you have your heartfelt song you
have your comedy song but then you have
the intro song and the hellfire song
this does what musicals are supposed to
do tell you how the person is feeling
and also explained the story in musical
form that is the purpose of a musical
and you know what they do a great hear
that choir is awesome it makes
everything seem so much more gigantic
and speaking of which the film is
gigantic I mean look at it
it's just huge for all the problems that
the movie has you can see why they made
it no true Dom looks unbelievable the
shadows the colors the angles much like
Bambi the sheer look of this film makes
everything seems so much grander and
much more important and give the movie
credit for Disney
this was very ballsy it's not
necessarily going after the church let's
face it they never get away with that
but it is sort of touching on issues of
faith and good and evil Heaven and Hell
got even lost the scene were an old man
schnitz the young woman's hair I
couldn't believe I was watching them
this is a Disney flick sex especially is
a big no-no in Disney and to see some of
this imagery come out was really kind of
shocking but personally I never thought
they went too far with it it fit kids
can see the good and thoughtful loving
relationships but they can also see the
bad and just mindless vengeful lust
there's also the issue of heartbreak the
main character doesn't get the woman
yeah I don't think I'm giving anything
away when I say that but at the same
time he's accepted among the crowd and
is able to start a new life as Disney
films go it's one of the darkest and
probably took the most risks and for the
most part it pays off the changes to the
story I actually don't mind so much
because for the most part it does flow
pretty well at times it's a little
clunky but again this is a very hard
adaptation to pull off in fact I'm
really amazed they pulled it off as well
as they did I know technically from a
character and storytelling point of view
it's not the strongest and for Disney to
fully make a version like this work it
either had to be more simpler or it just
go balls out and tell the entire story
you know screw the kids but you sort of
know that's not gonna happen in the same
way you know they're not gonna kill the
Little Mermaid in the Little Mermaid so
personally I really love this one it's
one of my favorites I don't care if it's
clunky I don't care if it has problems
the stuff that works really well works
unbelievably well and
sticks with you if you're a big fan of
the original Victor Hugo book you're
probably not gonna like this bird but if
you just say the title Disney's The
Hunchback of Notre Dom most people can
know what to expect and honestly I think
it's a little better than what most
people expect the audience for it is
growing more and more and I'm really
glad to see that because I don't think
it was a huge when I came out I don't
blame him after Pocahontas Disney was
just starting to become a little
unpopular and like I said something this
controversial was probably not the film
to get audiences back in but for what it
is it's a personal thing it took chances
through a lot of effort into it I've
seen it a million times and I'll
probably see it
[Music]
all right so Pocahontas was sort of the
beginning of the downfall of people's
interests and Disney animated movies
hunchback didn't exactly help Hercules
killed it this is one of the
most common using oddly put together I
don't even want to say Disney films just
films in general the choices they make
to tell this story or stories is just so
mind-boggling nothing about it makes
sense it's sort of like the Mad Libs of
Disney films a musical accompaniment
gonna be gospel okay the designer of the
movie is gonna be scar fade the guy who
did the wall okay the look and tone of
the movie is going to be Las Vegas I
what and the singer of the main song is
going to be Michael Ball oh you are dead
to me movie yeah I don't know what the
mindset was maybe they just wanted to
try something so different to sort of
get about the ditch but man does it
backfire okay well let's talk about the
story it's Greek mythology it got all
the gods up on Mount Olympus and Zeus is
happy because of the birth of his son
Hercules but Lord Hades the ruler of the
underworld wants to see his son get
destroyed because he's apparently gonna
stop him from taking over everything in
the future so he gives him a potion that
takes away his godly powers it's
interesting and much like Superman
Hercules has raised among people but
again just like Superman he finds out
that his father is a God among men that
he himself has supernatural powers and
just like Superman he goes to save the
day wherever he can with his incredible
strength and just like Superman you
seeing a pattern he falls in love with a
snarky woman who constantly has to be
saved but once Hades finds out that
Hercules is alive he tries to use the
woman they make her up to seduce him and
take away his powers
Hades uses her as bait to try and get
him to lower his powers away and that's
exactly what he does leaving Hades to
take over the land and Hercules to try
and stop him however he can
because in many respects the comparisons
to superhero shouldn't shock me I mean
it is served where the origin of
superheroes came from Greek mythology
but like I said it's the choices they
make in the way they tell this story
that just really makes it God Hercules
is not very interesting we've seen this
idiot before he's not very bright but
he's got a good heart he'll fall for
whatever stupid plan you put in front of
him but god she's just so wide-eyed you
can't help but feel sorry for
Megara is sassy but that's about it
there's not really much tour after that
yeah they tried to give her a pass but
she's still not that interesting she's
just a few one-liners and a sneer and
speaking of which that's exactly what
the teacher is to Danny DeVito plays
Danny DeVito yeah
he's the trainer he's Mickey from the
Rocky movies and again there's nothing
new to it except for the fact that's in
Greek mythology but why would we want to
see that the only thing that's kind of
entertaining is James Woods as Hades
because well again it's one of the weird
odd choices that I guess or works to its
advantage
I mean how strange that this guy doesn't
talk like a traditional villain he
stalks much more like a lawyer or agent
so I would be eternally grateful if you
would just take it enough we dance we
kiss which means we carry on we go home
happy what is it it's funny but he's not
enough to save the movie and all the
other side characters are just totally
forgettable
I love Scarface work but here it's
really not usable in something like the
wall it really shines because this work
is so different and strange in a movie
about Greek mythology maybe it could
work but not the way they're telling it
this isn't Greek mythology this is the
Excalibur Casino tells you the story of
Greek mythology the songs I don't
remember I barely even remember parts
where they did sit so what were they
thinking when they put this together the
only thing I can contemplate is that
maybe they were trying to go for
something similar to what they did with
a lab I mean like I said before Aladdin
was sort of Arabia meets Vegas but that
worked because the colors were so good
the designs were so good and there was
still chemistry
between the two main characters it's not
a new who was trying to please and it
had enough of a broad scope to reach a
general audience this does not not to
say that doesn't have its fans and short
dogs but I don't know when you look at
statues and sculptures of Hercules and
then you think Disney animation bringing
back to life this isn't what I think
which is fine if it was better or an
entertaining alternative but it's really
not it's clumsy it's flawed the story is
so a cycle the characters are so
recycled and not just from other Disney
film but other tire cliches as well this
is definitely one of my least favorites
maybe if it wanted to go full force into
straight ups and tire of the Hercules
stories which I'm not saying would
necessarily work but that's the only way
I can see these choices making sense but
when you still have to have a villain
who's intimidating a hero who's likable
on Romain's you're supposed to believe
and well actual suspense in the climax
you can't do this here and expect people
to be that investment like I said I hear
it's growing a bit of a fanbase but I
probably won't be able it's just a
little too weird
[Music]
one when it first came out was a modest
hit critics seem to like it okay nobody
insisting them like it okay and even
today that seems to be the general
consensus people seem to like it okay
yeah I guess I'm on the same boat but I
think I like it and dislike it for
different reasons everybody else does
what's the story a long time ago in
China we have the Huns invaded so an
army has to be put together and one male
from every house has to go and fight the
only problem is the father of a teenage
girl named Mulan is too old and too sick
to fight so she disguises herself as a
boy and goes to fight for it she's
accompanied by a Chinese dragon played
by Eddie Murphy yeah it wasn't that
fitted casting and while she has a hard
time fitting in she does eventually win
over the crowd never letting on to her
secret okay so what do people in general
really like about this movie well they
like the girl power aspect they like the
fact that such a strong female lead that
she goes out she flings a sword she
fights her battles she does all this
good stuff and man be great she was a
little bit more interest I don't want to
say she's a bore cuz she's not totally
forgettable but again I just feel like
I've seen this character before she's
the free spirit that everybody tells
should be one thing but she wants to be
something else she can't do the one
thing that everybody tells her to do so
she wants to go into something
unconventional and you know it that
unconventional thing changes everybody's
perception again not a bad moral I just
seen it and her character seems much
more tied to the moral than it does an
actual character well pulls her through
are the scenes where she's trying to be
a boy but look into that a second people
like Eddie Murphy as Mushu yeah I don't
he's he really out of place I didn't
laugh that much at him and I don't know
I didn't see a character I just saw
Eddie Murphy doing the voice of a
cartoon in something like Shrek it makes
a little bit more sense this is just the
kind of world it is in Chinese history
this doesn't seem to fly very well-known
to be fair he does get a good line
everyone
a couple of things I've noted found the
notice people like the Chinese culture I
think it's kind of under play again it's
kind of like Hercules just when you
think Disney animation is going to
tackle this you get really excited on
what they can do and aside from a few
backgrounds and one or two designs it's
pretty glanced over I guess Chinese art
in many ways does celebrate the white
space but I think there's a better way
to show it off there's a lot of great
Chinese art and I'd like to see it
explored more and then of course you
have the villain I'm not sure if people
like this guy or not but in my opinion I
think he is the most forgettable villain
ever put in Disney I don't remember a
thing about this guy his design is
boring his dialogue is boring what he
does is boring this is a fierce warrior
who burns down villages and yet I can't
remember one line out of him the only
thing I remember is that the color in
his eyes was reversed which I didn't
really get there's black where the white
should be and yellow where the black
should be I don't know if that's the
most memorable thing about him that's
probably not a good sign also I don't
like the fact that the ancient Chinese
ancestors again giving some kids have
real culture into this history is done
more like a meeting at the old folks
home I mean I know it's supposed to be
played for last but I just didn't find
that funny
again when you think Disney animation
and Chinese goes you think of something
really spectacular but this just seems
like a throwaway bitch in long bitchin
mo what do I like about this movie
honestly I like the comedy I know it
sounds weird seeing how it just bashed
Eddie Murphy and the ancestor ghost
people but I like everything else I like
the side characters I like this army
I like how they poked fun of gender
roles I like her attempts of trying to
fit in I like everybody trying to act
tough but failing miserably for me the
side characters is what makes this movie
particularly the army themselves I love
these guys I love the guy who's prone to
anger I love the one who's kind of a
passive
I love the other one whose campus
show-off I love the pencil pusher that
everybody makes fun of and like I said
what Mulan tries to blend in it's really
hilarious I actually think there's a
last subtlety to this humor too like if
you ever noticed when the one guy wanted
to shake hands she accidentally hands it
to him like she's expecting him to kiss
it
that's really kind of subtle plus the
comedic expressions are great and just
how quick they are oh hi guys I didn't
know you were here I was just washing so
now I'm clean and I'm gonna go bye-bye
though at times I have to omit some of
the gender issues get a little too weird
like when all the guys are whistling at
the women in the fields and then Millan
tries to cover her face while they laugh
no is that a little too odd maybe I'm
just over it for the most part they're
played pretty funny but again it's not
just the comedy that makes me enjoy it
it's the army in general I like the
camaraderie I like the individuals I
like that they try to work with one
another I like that they anger each
other I like that they make each other
laugh and I like Mulan trying to blend
in with them for me
that's where the heart of the movie is
so like I said before I think it's okay
certainly not one of the stronger Disney
films and I think it certainly could
have been a lot more but for what it is
it's got some good scenes I remember
liking it enough that I did sit down to
watch it again
which is more than I can say for some of
the other Disney films I think are
merely okay so in my opinion it's worth
at least one viewing I wouldn't expect a
whole lot of culture but I would expect
just the right amount of energy
[Music]
when I heard Disney's the next animated
feature was gonna be Tarzan I remember
thinking to myself yeah that sounds
about right I mean it is a pretty
well-known subject matter it does lend
itself to animation and at the same time
I was wondering if it might have the
same impact that Robin Hood had you know
where people would actually be
introduced to it through the Disney
version as opposed to other forms of
media
I saw the trailers and got really
excited for it and when it came out a
lot of it exceeded my expectations while
other parts we're kind of mediocre ok
well let's jump right in
a family is ship direct on an island and
they find they have to live on their own
but unfortunately a cheetah comes and
kills the parents leaving only the baby
behind coincidentally the exact same
cheetah kills the child of an ape family
and wouldn't you know it they happen to
bump into each other so the mother ape
decides she wants to look after the
child but the father ape is not quite as
positive so growing up the little boy
Tarzan has to not only win out his
friends who he seems to be an outcast in
front of but also his father who seems
to want nothing to do with them once he
grows into a man he comes across some
more people a hunter named clean a
bubbling oil professor and his daughter
named Jane Jane and Tarzan immediately
start to hit it on and Jane stressed to
show him all about the human world while
he's stressed to show her all about the
animal world the romance is born and of
course an evil villain is discovered ok
so what's good about the movie
well the animation I mean yeah look at
what they can do what Tarzan is
unbelievable before this people would
just associate him with swing around on
vines but look at this he's practically
surfing the trees that's really creative
Tarzan himself is a great decent
character I mean he does all the stuff
you wanted to do he snarled he sneers he
roars but he does have those big
puppy-dog eyes and he does manage to be
sentimental and certain office
Jane is my example of a damsel in
distress done right I mean yeah not
every character has to be strong not
every character has to be wielding a
sword but they have to at least be
interesting and Jane despite the fact
that she has to be saved all the time
arresting she's polite but she's
eccentric she's clumsy but she's got a
good heart and it sort of makes sense
that she'd had to be saved all the time
I mean she's out of her environment and
this is very much how women were like at
that time period but she still
contributes and being the education for
Tarzan and also the emotional center so
yeah I think she's a fun character Rosie
up Donald isn't a band yeah I won't say
ideal cast because let's face it
everybody else already has and while she
is annoying she's not as annoying as she
could've been waitin and I don't think
I'm giving anything away here is
obviously the bad guy he's kind of like
Gaston except - any of the comedy -
charm he's not very interesting and his
motivation is as boring as the Disney
motivations again it's just greed it's
the Pocahontas villain all over again
the motivation is boring he's boring it
slows everything down the rest of the
site characters are kind of forgettable
but to be fair they keep the focus where
it should be on Tarzan the songs are by
Phil Collins wait what
come College what does he have to do
with Disney your jungle or anything like
that well okay maybe he'll write some
good songs for the characters to sing oh
no they're not singing at all
he's just singing the songs right though
out of nowhere every time you start
singing I expect all the animals to
start looking around saying is that
sometimes the orchestration surround the
songs can be nice but the actual songs
themselves they don't do a thing for me
it I guess he sort of sings about what's
going on but kind of in the same way
that hey this can be played on the radio
as well it's all two things if the songs
not totally invested in what it's
singing about the why should we but I
think my main issue with the movies the
conflict that Tarzan is going which
don't get me wrong it is there and it is
addressed and they do take time out of
the movie to look at it but I just wish
they took more time I was kind of
thinking to myself Wow
Disney Animation and the turmoil of
Tarzan what they can do with this half
man-half
I mean there's so many different
variations you can do with animation
it's that sort of thinking of something
along the lines of Hellfire like
visually showing the turmoil that the
person is going through as well as a
musical form you know as opposed to Phil
Collen singing at times and here yeah oh
wait no not Tarzan cuz that'd be too
specific I'm feeling something that this
character's feeling - the cult but
instead it's sort of fighting for room
with the comic relief and the villain
and again the Phil Collins songs and I
don't know I guess I just want much more
of that to be the focus even the romance
between Tarzan and Jane could explore it
a little bit more I mean I guess it
works all right but again it feels like
they're trying to squeeze in too much
that's not totally needed like its
childhood you could have really gone
into him trying to fit in and yeah they
do but it's mostly played for laughs I
like the scene where he tries to cover
himself in mud and to himself into an
eighth but that's only for a few seconds
and the same thing when he meets Jane
for the first time he takes off her
glove touches a human hand for the first
time and it's a nice scene but again
it's only a few seconds I guess I wanted
more of his internal struggle to take up
the majority of the film but then again
it is Disney I mean I can't expect all
the characters to be like furlough and
Hunchback of Notre Dom I mean maybe I'm
just in spoiled it's just this thought
that Disney wants to get better and
better and in many respects they are so
when a Disney film doesn't take
advantage of a really great opportunity
especially when it looks like you only
have one shot at it
it's kind of a letdown especially when
it's just thrown away - the same greedy
plot device that the villain provides
you know what they're in the jungle
why do they need a villain everything's
already trying to get them in fact why
didn't they make the cheetah the villain
he's the one that killed a kid a pair of
parents why couldn't they make that like
a Shere Khan tied villain that would
have been so much more interesting but
again I'm probably trying to see it for
what I want it to be as opposed to what
it is but what it is that's good the
animation has some great moments I do
like our two main characters there is
actually time set aside for character
development
just not as much as I would like on the
whole Tarzan is a good flick to check
out so the next time you see that DVD
keep it in rent you probably enjoy
[Music]
well the sequel to one of my favorite
films of all time has finally come out
Fantasia mm this is what Walt Disney
originally wanted to do he want to
continue the Fantasia legacy by having
new movies come out but since the first
one didn't do so hot they decided to
scrap that idea however the popularity
for Fantasia kept building and they
decided to finally do a sequel years
later it's fantastic it's brilliant it's
stupid and lame it's new and inspiring
it's old and it's been done it's a
creative magical experience it's a
complete sellout by every means of the
word so as you can imagine my emotions
run pretty high with this movie but in
keeping with the Disney tradition the
stuff that's good is really really good
I guess the best way to go about is just
to talk about the segments it starts off
with Beethoven's fifth symphony and
they're trying to do what they deal with
the first film by having the abstract
art try to man to the music at times it
does but for the most part it's trying
to tell a story like how there's this
mama butterfly and this baby butterfly
and they try to get away from these evil
black butterflies and yeah if it's
trying to go abstract white trying to
put a coherent narrative to it and on
top of that sometimes the coherent
narrative doesn't match the music so it
doesn't even work in that sense but it's
got a few good visuals in there next we
have the pines of Rome with the flying
whales this is awesome the CG makes the
size and weight of the whales just look
gigantic it matches the music perfectly
and on top of that it just builds and
builds at the end
in fact this probably would have been
better as the last one but you know what
can you do the story the tin soldier is
okay though like most Disney films they
change the ending around it matches the
music imagines to be a cute little fairy
tale Rhapsody in Blue is a new take not
only in music but in style too they take
sort of an Al Hirschfeld style to the
whole thing yeah it works really well it
matches the music nice and it's good to
see Disney try something new especially
with Fantasia
the Flamingo with a yo-yo yeah
just say that out loud there's a
flamingo with a yo-yo that's the focus
of one of the musical segments in a
Fantasia movie well you can guess my
problem it's cute but really you could
see that on Tiny Toons or something it
doesn't seem like Fantasia related they
free play The Sorcerer's Apprentice
that's always fun
and then we get Donald's Ark which again
is funny and cute but let's face it
every time you hear that music you're
gonna think of graduation and it's kind
of distracting
[Music]
it gets a few laughs though so I guess
it works fine and the last one is the
Firebird Suite again some of Disney's
best animation here mixing some of their
classic style of animation but also
mixing some new stuff is it me or does
that sprite look very animation well
this one matches the music great it
looks great and it's a nice finale
though again the wheels would have been
a little better but I'm just nitpicking
unfortunately we also have celebrity
appearances that's Steve Martin probably
at is worse
can I have my violin please ah thank you
sorry could I have another stick thingy
please we also have been Mahler James
Earl Jones Angela Lansbury Penn & Teller
L forgot a Penn & Teller really it's
like when they invited beavis and
butt-head to the Oscars just something
doesn't seem right here some of them can
add a little bit of class and dignity
but most of them are just spending time
either congratulating what a great movie
is even before it's done and the rest of
them are just making really painful
jokes oh yeah the look on that woman's
face says it all the original Fantasia
had a dignity to it like they were gonna
treat the audience seriously like hey
this was for adult we're not gonna talk
down to you this is some of the greatest
music ever written we worked really hard
on this and we're gonna treat it that
way
here it's Steve Barton so on the whole
Fantasia 2000 is pretty hit and miss but
to be honest the only major miss would
probably be the celebrities I can't
think of any musical segments where I
was just like wow that was awful I mean
even the ones that aren't very good are
just not very good by Fantasia standards
but they're still fine on their own
and as I said before the stuff that's
good is incredibly good this is some of
Disney's best animation in years it
allows them to just be creative do what
they want just let the animation breathe
there's a sense that there wasn't as
many limitations to this and you know
what it really does show half the time
the other half not so much so honestly
despite his flaws I still highly
recommend it is it the first film no do
any of them meet the power seriousness
of the
first film no but some of them do come
close overall I really like it yeah I
hate sitting through the celebrities and
some of the other musical segments as
much as you do but the payoff it's just
too good of a payoff I say definitely
check it out just have the fast-forward
button on standby
[Music]
when I saw the previews for the
Emperor's New Groove I just said okay
I'm done no more Disney they have
clearly given up what David Spade is a
llama really this is your movie these
are the people that brought us Snow
White and Sleeping Beauty and The Lion
King and David Spade as a llama no just
no but after years and years of
everybody telling me you've got to see
the average New Groove you got to see
the Emperor's New Groove I finally broke
down and I put it on and better than I
thought but I don't know if that makes
it good at least not for me well okay
let's talk about it David Spade plays an
emperor that's totally full of himself
in a complete jerk so an evil sorceress
and her bumbling sidekick tried to put
him out of his misery and take control
of the crown but they accidentally
slipped him a potion that turns him into
a llama instead of killing him well they
tried kill him anyway
but the sidekick messes up and
accidentally lets him get away
so the llama comes across a peasant
played by John Goodman as you'd imagine
they don't get along they backstab one
another and yeah it's pretty much a
buddy buddy comedy do I even need to say
what's gonna happen in the end they're
gonna go on their road trip they're
gonna become friends they're gonna
figure out something about one another
and of course they're gonna defeat the
bad guys I guess what people really like
about this movie is all the adult humor
and fourth-wall jokes I guess a good
chunk of the time they do work I mean I
can't think of a joke swear I was just
smacking my head saying Oh God really
they said that but I can also think of
many jokes write it laugh
it's probably no secret I'm not a big
fan of David Spade and yeah I'd be lying
if I said I liked him a lot here but
much like Rosie O'Donnell and Tarzan
he's not that annoying John Goodman is
John Goodman
yeah just serve his typical nice guy you
know it works but I've seen it
beside characters I guess are just the
people they come across on their
journeys and I don't remember too many
of them but again I don't remember a man
being super annoying honestly I just
don't want to see Disney do a
buddy-buddy roadtrip movie I mean
it's Disney I'm expecting great big
grand things or if they are gonna do a
comedy a great big grand comedy if you
want to see a buddy-buddy roadtrip movie
from them that's fine
but when I hear Disney I think grand
Animation I think the best of the best
not David Spade as oh haha so really I
think everything in this movie is just
kind of okay with the exception of one
element the villains Eartha Kitt and
Patrick Warburton are friggin hilarious
they make this movie every scene with
them makes me laugh and makes me laugh
hard it's such a peculiar team-up but
you know what it really works
the voices the expressions and
especially the animation on them are
just wonderful I think that's something
that I should bring up the animation in
this as far as comedy goes is really
really good the timings really fast and
the line work is really good so I will
give the film credit for that but like I
said the only thing that really stands
out for me are the villains in fact I
really wish the movie was just about the
two of them what as is it's just your
typical buddy-buddy road trip like I
said and if you're looking for a Disney
version event I guess you'll like this
fine but it doesn't do much for me like
I said not as bad as I thought but just
nothing spectacular
[Music]
Atlantis the lost Empire
this was Disney's attempt to try and be
a little bit more adult in that they're
trying to make an action film where
people die and big explosions happen and
all that cool stuff to try get back with
the hip audience again and boy did it
backfire not only did the film do
incredibly poorly at the box office but
critics really ripped it a new I mean it
seemed like nobody liked this movie at
all where the criticisms right yeah but
I don't know I think there's some good
stuff man
all right let's look at the story
Michael J Fox is Milo a janitor at a
museum but it turns out he has a journal
that could possibly lead to the lost
civilization of Atlantis which of course
nobody believes him on that is except
for one man who used to be a friend of
his family it turns out he believes Milo
and has been spending years and years
putting together a team and equipment to
go down and actually fight it of course
they come across trouble obstacles and
all sorts of bad things trying to get in
the way until they finally find the city
and the lost people they come across the
Emperor and his daughter named Keita and
they try to figure out the ways of the
culture and civilization as it turns out
the culture and civilization themselves
have forgotten it that's sort of an
interesting idea okay so this sort of
sounds like 20,000 Leagues meets Indiana
Jones meets well Disney there is a lot
of action there is a lot of adventure
but at the same time yeah you do have to
mix it with Disney don't you and if
you're trying to get more of an adult
crowd that's probably not the best thing
to do like listen to this line and tell
me if you think this is more Indiana
Jones or Disney Princess we
we're gonna die trying yeah I'd say
Disney too on top of that guess who the
villain is that's right some asshole who
just wants money over God's sake you're
looking for a lost civilization you're
gonna be rich either way but no they
want to destroy the people and just take
the artifact so it's worth even more
money Oh gimme a break I am so sick of
these guys but what does work about the
movie well the culture is pretty cool
the people are pretty cool the sort of
magical elements are pretty cool and the
top of that I really like the side
characters they're all very unique very
funny they all stand out and they have
some really good lines I'd be lying if I
said the problems I listed before didn't
get in the way and yeah the hole is it a
good movie probably not but I think this
is sort of from me what will our Rouge
is for a lot of voters about guilty
pleasure the stuff that's good I think
is really good and really holds up
it's a cornea times oh yeah is it really
stupid you have no idea but look at this
scene
[Music]
in my opinion there's more here to make
it just a style over substance I mean
the culture is very interesting the
people are pretty interesting the
designs are very interesting like I said
I do like a lot of these characters in
fact it's one of the few times you have
a Disney couple that doesn't get married
they don't even kiss they just give a
hug dude that's rare but the problems
are major ones and they can be very very
distracting and can ruin the film for a
lot of people it didn't for me
okay keep close but the stuff that's
good I really enjoyed I'm sure it has
its fans I'm sure it has its haters you
can just put me in the fan category I
really liked it despite its annoyances
it's not perfect but I had a lot of fun
watching
[Music]
every once in a while you come across
that movie that's supposed to be one
thing but it does one element so well
that it actually almost works against it
lilo and Stitch is one of those movies
the story is very basic and alien
experiment from another galaxy escapes
his captivity mix this way to earth and
be front a little girl named little the
other aliens tried to get him back while
they also learn the meaning of family
blah blah blah blah blah you can guess
it very quickly I remember I saw the
trailers for this movie and I was
thinking to myself I should have already
know this story it's kind of et ich
meets hiding a pet meets family bonding
yeah I know it I know it so I basically
avoided it but much like the Emperor's
New Groove everybody was telling me to
see it so I finally went rented it sat
down and watched it and here's what
stuck out to me the stuff with the
little girl is unbelievable this is
probably one of the best Kade characters
of all time and for Disney to accomplish
that that's really something their kid
characters have ranged from okay to
incredibly annoying and incredibly bland
but this character she's weird she's
violent she's bizarre she's emotional
she's kooky she's totally out of control
hey guess what those are kids it just so
happens she's even more stranger than
the rest of the crowd so that makes her
even more interesting god Disney finally
got this right but it doesn't just stop
there Oh what is there an evil mother or
an evil step something or other that
doesn't understand her or something no
it's actually a very believable
situation leavel has to live with her
older sister because the parents sadly
passed away but the older sister has
trouble looking out for her because
she's constantly in between jobs has to
look after a kid that's already a
handful and on top of that she's her
older sister not her parent so this is
new territory for both of them and it's
hard for them to both get used to it
there's a man from an agency who's
constantly watching them making
that Lila sister is a good parent but
even then he's not the bad guy he's just
doing his job and at times he sees the
tragedy of the situation too and that's
what this is a tragedy
it's just a really bad turn of events
that creates a really bad situation
it doesn't need a bad guy it doesn't
need a greedy villain it's just life
it's the first time I thought Disney
really got that and they really captured
it and for me this is bringing their
animated features to a whole new level
but sadly the film is not entirely about
that it's also about the alien and that
stuff is just ok it's not bad it's not
great it's just decent the aliens cute I
guess they have to sort of train him
like a dog and of course he learns the
meaning of family just as they learn the
meeting of family I know it I know it it
gets a few laughs and the friendship
between the two of them is relatively
strong it's just oh man I wish the movie
was just about the sister in lilo and
when you constantly had to be pulled
back to the sci-fi alien chase it sort
of disappoints you
well me I should say but like I said
it's not bad it just turns out they did
one element way too well but to be fair
and that's better than having the whole
film just be mediocre and much like
Tarzan I shouldn't analyze what I wanted
to be as much as what it is and for what
it is it is really good the animation is
great like I said these two characters
are great the aliens they're okay I mean
I guess you do sort of grow to like
stitch and some of the side characters
get a few giggles the backgrounds
actually return to watercolor
backgrounds that's really rare for
Disney yeah it was sort of a nice
comeback it was also nice that took
place in Hawaii again trying to get sort
of a different location so on the whole
it is a good movie there's just some
parts that are so much better than
others and I really would have liked to
have seen that explore it a little bit
more but it's still good flick and the
stuff that stands out is really
fantastic
the aliens are okay but the sisters are
more than worth the price of admission
[Music]
Treasure Planet just saying that name
sounds kind of silly and I'm not gonna
lie that's sort of the major issue I
have with this movie its Treasure Island
only we're not telling it like most
people tow Treasure Island we're telling
it in space in the future but the
spaceships aren't really spaceships
they're water
ships but the people are dressed
futuristically at least some of them the
ones not wearing bonnets and okay let's
start from the beginning
a young Jim Hawkins hears about the
legend of buried treasure only like we
said before it's not a Treasure Island
it's on Treasure Planet years go by and
Jim Hawkins it turns out is now a
delinquent always getting in trouble and
feeling bad that his father left Wow is
that really in a Disney film no car
accident no tragic death he actually
just up and left
Wow that's actually pretty rare well
anyway his mother has a hard enough time
trying to raise him while also trying to
look after a restaurant but all that
changes when he comes across a treasure
map their treasure sphere whatever that
apparently shows them the location of
Treasure Planet he comes across one of
his mother's friends called dr. dopler
and he recommends that they find a ship
and go looking for the treasure
the mother Zaarly agrees and thus Jim
and Doppler are off on adventure the
captain this time around is a cat lady I
don't mean she likes cats I mean
literally she's half cat half lady
played by Emma Thompson the cook is John
Silver played by Brian Murphy and he
also comes across a few other little
friends like this little glob of goo
named morph a robot voiced by Martin
Short and all sorts of other weird
oddities okay so what's good about the
movie because actually there are a lot
of good things about it first of all it
gets down what I think really any Disney
film should get down first the
relationships with the characters for
example the relationship between Hawkins
and his mother is great relationship
between him and John Silver is great the
relationship between dopler and the
captain is great enter the film's credit
the reason the relationships are so
great is because all the characters are
pretty darn good too
Hawkins is sort of your generic
rebellious hero but
at the same time they do leave it open
for people to leave impressions on you
will absorb what people are telling him
that's a good trait for a character the
captain is a lot of fun she's very
dignified very intelligent but she's
also a fast talker and likes to show off
Doppler at times can get annoying and
yeah I'm not a fan of the Martin Shaw
robot but he's not anymore
John Silber is great as the character
should be both being diabolical but also
having a soft side for Hawkins so ok it
seems to follow the book pretty well the
characters are strong what's actually
wrong with this film this seems like the
most important stuff well last I said
before it's the setting why is this set
in the future ok let me point this way
you can set it in the future that's fine
but go all out if you want to show a
spaceship show a spaceship some
cool-looking ones when you just have
giant boats in space that's all we're
gonna see you have futuristic
parasailing in the sky but then you also
have people in 19th century dress
honestly it's just distracting sometimes
it really works like all the mechanics
on John Silver instead of just having a
fake leg he has a fake arm a fake eye
and all of its technologically advanced
that's pretty cool I just wish the rest
of the movie went that far instead of
trying to create this world that they
just wanted to create on its own they
kept trying to combine it with what was
popular what was advanced and then what
was also so true of the time period the
book was written and that just serves
out a cluttered mess and I don't think
it's a pet peeve because it's constantly
distracting I'm always asking how do
these two things go together these are
two totally different time periods that
really have almost nothing to do with
one another you can borrow some things
but this is really weird on top of that
the same way that something like Oliver
and company felt very manipulative you
know like half the visuals was something
a marketing agent came up with yeah you
feel that throughout the entire movie I
mean it opens with sky surfing all I
could think of was that opening in the
Power Rangers movie where they go sky
surfing - it's like really look you can
relate with Jim Hawkins he's doing cool
stuff ooh
he wears a short black jacket he has a
cool haircut he's got a ponytail rad he
goes to his mother who looks like
something out of Moby Dick wait what so
yeah I wasn't on board with the idea I
constantly felt like I was being
manipulated and really I wanted to see
Disney do Treasure Island no gimmicks no
whatever's cool at the time just tell
Treasure Island
so I guess my final sum up is when they
do tell Treasure Island that's good and
when they tried to do something cool and
hip it's lame sometimes the sci-fi
designs are neat but mostly it's just
distracting I don't know if you can look
at these visuals and they don't bother
you in fact you actually find yourself
getting into it but you'll probably like
this movie fine for me it just
constantly took me out of it I know I'd
like to have seen the original source
material really come to life as told by
Disney but it's not horrible it's not
even really that bad I could just never
get into it as much as the movie wants
me to get into it hopefully you can draw
your own conclusions and you can see if
this movie is worth your time
[Music]
what I agreed to do Disney cember
brother bear was one of the films I was
looking the least forward to reviewing
okay not the least but we'll get to that
one later Michael Mike we've seen the
trailers for than just looking
incredibly uninterested and yeah I guess
everybody else did because the NuvaRing
well I sat down I watched it and I have
to say at first I was freaking blown
away by it
the people were likeable and the myths
were likeable all I was saying to myself
was holy smokes this is what Pocahontas
should have been I was getting invested
in these characters I was getting
invested in what happened to them one
character passes away very early on and
you know what I was really sort of torn
up about it
the music was nice the animation was
nice I was totally digging it and then
our main character turns into a bear
this is where it all goes down okay let
me clarify I have no problem with the
main character turn me into a bear to
learn a lesson in fact I was actually
against it when I heard about it but see
where they were going with everything
else actually pretty excited now they
handled everything else so well I wanted
to see what they were gonna do with this
what they do with it is about as
predictable and boring and lame as you
can imagine you see the spirit of the
mountain or something like that takes
the body of a young man who's looking
for revenge on a bear and actually turns
him into a bear well he of course wants
to turn back to human and comes across
some colorful characters along the way
one of them is a little cub named Koda
he hangs around him for a bit because
apparently he got separated from his
mother well gee I wonder what happened
to the mother I won't give anything away
but let's just say something happened to
the mother and you'll be really
dumbfounded that throughout this entire
film the main character never figures
out what happened to the mother and
throughout the whole film the bear is
trying to get to the top of the mountain
to figure out how to change himself back
all the while his human brother is
trying to track down and kill the bear
because he wants vengeance too so in a
clip a bit of writing there's no
real villain there's just a great big
misunderstanding the brother wants to
kill the bear for a reason we can all
understand he was revenge for his
brother and while of course we see it's
misled we can sense the passion and the
love they had for his brother hence why
he's going to such violent deeds in fact
this whole story turned out to be a
pretty good setup it had a good
beginning it had a good ending but like
I said the middle is where the problem
comes from when the animals have to talk
it's pretty annoying the language the
humans had for the most part is pretty
timeless but here the animals say stuff
like dude and I Spy and a pinky swear
and do all sorts of other modern things
that people do and I'm sorry that's
really distracting and on top of that it
doesn't make us connect as well to the
characters what you were doing before
was great we were connecting with the
people because we were connecting with
their culture and their passion and
their beliefs and their myths if I was
driving this never would have happened
yes not even let me drive you can't
believe you totaled a mammoth that kind
of takes us out of the magic the kid he
has to look after is really annoying
again you have to be really careful with
a little boy who's trying to act tough
because that can either turn out really
annoying or really charming this is
really annoying surprisingly at first I
was really getting into the music yeah I
thought it was sounding really nice I
saw that Phil Collins was attached to
this and I dreaded it but when I was
hearing that opening music you know what
I was really into it but then
you just couldn't stay out of it could
you Phil okay well maybe he'll just be
like Tarzan where he's kind of annoying
but he's not actually ruining anything
the bear is telling the cub what
happened to the mother and Phil Collins
is singing over it oh you Phil
Collins you or the person who
put the song here or the person who
had the idea put a song here I write a
song about it somebody this is the
worst placement for a song ever
guys why couldn't you just go with the
musical score here I mean really you
need Phil Collins to come in and sing
it's sad that this pot is sad that
you're supposed to cry right now that's
a very sad though whoo look he's ready
torn up I'm not gonna let the scene just
play I'm gonna tell you how to feel oh
hi Phil Collins you ah so yeah the
obvious plot that anybody can figure out
the modern talk of Phil Collins songs
you'd really think I hate this movie and
well yeah I do really hate parts of it
but David those other parts are so good
I mean talk about being so close and yet
so far
well again morally I guess nothing bad
is being said and I guess it could be
worse I mean they don't quote any movies
or anything like that
but no it was so close you almost had
this really perfect wonderful Disney
movie engine down Phil Collins butter
talk pinkie swear oh it frustrates me
but on the other hand I guess I really
didn't expect anything to come out of
this movie if they have the good parts
that did come out of it I guess that was
pretty cool and you know what it is nice
to see that Disney can still get some
culture in their animated films whether
or not the culture is correct I don't
know because I myself AM on culture but
even if it's not it still makes for
interesting myth and interesting stories
so yeah I love the beginning I love the
ending the Milken Succot yeah I realized
this review is kind of all over the
place but that's really what I thought
would I see it again probably not I
guess I am glad that I did in fact see
it wants hopefully you can take what I
said and also sort of look at the
trailer and see if this is something
that be up your alley well either wait
take a look at and see for yourself
[Music]
all right let's get this over with home
on the range yes okay out of all the
Disney films I was gonna see for Disney
simper this is the one I wanted to see
the least and let me tell you folks it
didn't disappoint
it gave me exactly what I thought I was
going to get oh god do I hate this film
this is right up there with the
Aristocats just no creativity no
spontaneity no passion no effort just
pure phoned-in Ness I'll tell you the
story because really you can figure out
pretty quickly if you'll like this film
or not
Rosanna is a common well I'd press stop
after that fact but let's keep going
she's just been sold to a farm with
other cows and everything is happy and
chipper they dance they smile they yeah
but then they find out that the farm is
being closed down so the cows figure
that if they bring this bandit to
justice and get the reward money they
can use that to save the farm and that's
it the rest is cows going after an evil
villain
it's about as half-assed as you can
imagine okay now let me make one thing
clear when I say half-assed I mean
half-assed for Disney
I know animation is hard I know that by
most normal standards this is still
pretty good animation and I know that by
most bad films and even bad children's
films consider this isn't that
horrendous but if somebody told you that
this was from the greatest animation
company in the entire world admitted
you'd be alone cheesed off to you would
want to see more effort from something
that's so massive and so large and this
is a movie that's obviously just geared
towards little kids I mean really little
kids toddlers the jokes aren't for
adults the writing isn't for adults the
characters aren't for adults even the
animation style isn't really for adults
and again that was the magic with Disney
they hit both they could hit both the
kids and the adults but here
it's just for kids the only thing I
remember remotely laughing it was
jennifer Tilly as this one can't be eyes
it's Jennifer Tilly she's always fun
aside from that I remember so little the
songs are forgettable the characters are
forgettable the Imagi sness of how
bright and colorful and smiley it is oh
it's like something out of Barney the
Dinosaur is something it just doesn't
seem like Disney or maybe it does but
not updated Disney not current Disney
not the Disney that kept us coming back
wanting more not the passion not the
drive how do we even know what else to
say about it it's just with a lot of
these Disney films I was forced to watch
this month I came across a few surprises
sadly there was no surprise with this
one at all unless you're only a few
years old or younger I say this is a
definite
[Music]
okay so I'm cheating a little bit with
this one as a lot of people to sort of
consider this as an okay maybe not
considered but it's a satire of at
Disney anime in flesh done by Disney
animation so it's kind of hard not to
talk about it
enchanted starts off in a faraway land
and animated faraway lands there's a
handsome prince he has an evil mother
and he wants to marry a beautiful
peasant but the mother doesn't want them
to marry and so banishes her to another
Kingdom that is to say our Kingdom the
real world yes isn't that gimmicky she
comes across a father and daughter in
New York City who take pity on her and
decide to take her in she acts the way
most of the leading females act from
Disney animated films er well Laura the
Europeans and it turns out she manages
to bring a little magic into their lives
but then other people start to show up
including the dashing Prince and the
evil mother the dashing Prince of course
is all smiles and heroics while the
mother is all evil and sorcery and while
spending time in the quote unquote real
world they find that some of the ways
they've been acting in their cartoony
world doesn't seem very logical
for example the peasant decides to ask
the Prince to go out on a date they also
discovered that the stationery roles
that they're so used to staying in don't
have to be there all the time
a woman can be strong a man can be weak
and so on and so forth okay well you get
the gist of it so how's the movie well
it does have some good laughs in it
especially just from the performances
the peasant and the Prince aren't
especially funny I mean they just crack
me up whenever they're on screen and I
do like the fact that as much as our
world tries to force reality on them
their world can force their magic onto
us
like sometimes they'll break into song
sequences animals will suddenly be
cleaning up all that good stuff
I guess what bothers me a little bit is
the fact that it is a Disney film and
that really what they're satirizing is
more over the top than the
give it credit for honey number one the
film's there satirizing really are the
films like Snow White and Cinderella the
more modern fairy tales don't quite go
as this goofy that is except for this
one line and this does make me laugh
[Music]
that is spot-on but aside from that the
whole idea that the princesses always
have to be damsels and that the princes
always have to save the date no it seems
like with Beauty and the Beast and Mulan
Aladdin and stuff they've mixed it up a
bit I mean okay it's not perfect and
they do sometimes go back into those
roles but I think even Disney knows that
they come further than this movie is
giving a credit for on top of that it
works when they're playing it up for
last but the last third where Susan
Sarandon is quoting every obvious
stereotype man does that get annoying
this is a twist on our story it's the
brave little princess I guess that makes
you the damsel in distress we're coming
at the end of our story now
Polly ever after it's time to take our
yes we get it
things are switched around you see in my
opinion when you really want change to
happen you just sort of do it you don't
draw a ton of attention to it I guess
I'm very much a by example person that
way here when you draw too much
attention to it it sort of feels like
you're focusing in a stereotype that you
may or may not have known existed like
maybe you had a girl who is a tomboy it
wasn't into princesses and then you find
out oh you were supposed to be this way
but now we're telling you it's okay or
how about a boy who wasn't into fighting
and rescues but then you find out oh no
this is what you're supposed to be
except now we've given you permission
not to be then again maybe by drawing
more attention to it they feel like
they're slapping to use you in the face
but I don't know isn't the female lead
holding a sword not really that shocking
anymore isn't the fact that a guy has to
be rescued once in a while that's so
risque don't dwell on it so much except
for the fact that that Mohit Welles on
it so much what let's be honest what
enchanted really wanted to be was a
romantic comedy for kids mostly for
adults so in a sense they overplayed the
childish stereotypes because well it'll
get a bigger laugh out of the adults
because that's what they remember
growing up with Snow White Cinderella
and so forth I guess I just get a little
nervous thinking that this could
possibly be a kids first Disney when
obviously it's satirizing Disney pretend
even then not phenomenally well I mean
it's funny but more for the characters
they create not for the ones they're
satirising okay I'm a mixed bag but I
find I do enjoy it can we get down to it
I guess it is harmless but what would
this mean for Disney would this mean
that the 2d animation studio is back
after such a long and horrible hiatus
well we'll find out in the next
[Music]
for a while the Disney 2d animation
studio was shut down this is because the
last few movies that were made were not
huge financial successes aviemore even
critical successes so after a long time
away disney decide to finally return to
its roots go back to the fairy tales go
back to the happily ever afters go back
to the magical stuff this is where the
princess in the frog comes in let me
tell you I was excited to see an
animated 2d Disney film on the big
screen again and not just a satire one I
mean a real one and personally in my
opinion it didn't disappoint okay story
you got a young woman named Tiana she
has a dream of opening her own
restaurant after her father passes away
I guess some Disney traditions never do
truly die she works her butt off to save
as much money as she can well that's
going on a prince from a faraway land
named Prince Naveen comes into town his
parents cut off his finances because
he's too much of a party animal but then
he comes across the shadow man he tricks
not being into having him agreed to have
his soul be put into a frog
while his assistant would take on the
appearance of the prince and also worked
for the Shadow Man at a costume party
Naveen confuses Tiana for a princess and
asks her to kiss him she agrees hoping
as riches will help keep her restaurant
open but seeing how she wasn't a true
princess she gets turned into a frog -
and the rest of the movie is them trying
to figure out how to lift the curse and
how to stop the evil Shadow Man let's
look at our characters Tiana is probably
the best female lead since she's a fast
thinker she's positive and she's a
workaholic God never thought you see
that in the Disney Princess which oh the
prince is also a lot of fun he's full of
himself but he's also got a lot of
innocence too
Tiana's best friend is hilarious
I haven't seen a Disney character this
funny in a long time
every second she is on screen she just
cracks me up a villain is also a lot of
fun the fact that he's into voodoo
allows for a lot of creative visuals and
a lot of great possibilities and they
take advantage of them all the other
reasons of the site characters are also
very memorable you got alligator who
wants to be a musician a redneck Firefly
who thinks he's in love with a star in
the sky and a witch doctor who always
has the answer to every question so ok
this film sounds about as good as the
classic traditional great Disney movies
what could possibly go wrong with it
well there's only one problem
and sadly it's kind of a big one the
story it's not that it's bad it's just a
little too complicated I mean ok I told
you the basics but I didn't even tell
you about the fact that what the Shadow
Man has a deal with the underworld so
that he can take control of the town but
in order to take control the town he has
to have the guy who looks like the
prince married the daughter of the mayor
of the town but in order to do that they
constantly need the blood of the Frog
Prince to constantly give to that guy or
else his disguise will fade away but it
turns out the prince has to be kissed by
the daughter of the mayor because the
mayor always appoints himself the king
of the parade which technically makes
her a princess but if that has to be
done before midnight on a certain day
but on top of that you also have to have
the two main characters fall in love
with each other while they're
discovering how to fix their own falls
as well as each other's oh and I
mentioned that there's also a totally
unnecessary death and a totally goofy
silly funeral scene that'll either make
you laugh or cry or both oh my god it's
too much
I always said that this should have been
called loophole in the movie because
that's what it always seems like every
second they're trying to look for a new
loophole to get around something now is
it a major problem
I guess not because you're constantly
guessing what's gonna happen but what
are the charms of movies like The Little
Mermaid Beauty the Beast Aladdin and so
forth is that the stories were always
very flowing they know exactly how much
to give to the characters and exactly
how much to give to the details this
movie has way too many
but like I said it's not that bad it's
just not as good as the other Disney
flicks handbook together yes the songs
are Randy Newman songs and to be fair
two of them are pretty good friends on
the other side is a great villain and
almost there actually has a very
memorable nice beat to it the others I
don't remember and again I guess that is
a problem with the movie but again to
the movies credit it does take place in
New Orleans and at least the musical
style does man even it's not all
memorable I guess before I wrap up I'd
you talk about some of the controversy
that surrounded this of course Tiana was
the first black princess and there was a
lot of talk about the fact that
originally she was supposed to be a
chambermaid they changed it and made her
a waitress but that caused a lot uproar
- oh it's changing history oh it's
changing the way things were back then
well you know what there's a
talking frog I think we'll live yeah
it's changing things but you know what
we're always gonna have reminders of how
things really work
this is a fairy tale let the kids have
their fairy tale on top of that there's
also controversy about why the film
didn't do as well as Disney was hoping
now it didn't Bob let me clarify that
but it wasn't the gigantic hit they were
hoping for was it racism was the world
just not ready for a black princess yet
I guess it could be but I have my own
theory I think it is the prejudice but
it's not against black people
it's against hand-drawn films it's been
a while since one has been marketed to
both adults and kids and let's be honest
this is still a family picture and the
majority of family pictures coming out
nowadays are either live-action or 3d
personally I think a lot of adults still
see hand-drawn films as kid stuff now it
could give people in the seas if it was
really doing something new like The
Little Mermaid or just did a spectacular
Lea like Beauty and the Beast and to be
fair even though I like this film it
really didn't it updated the fairy tale
very nicely and very cleverly but the
problems with the story do hold it back
from being anything spectacular and like
I said before only a few of the Randy
Newman songs are memorable
there's no be our guest in there so
that's my theory but to be honest it
still made money I'd be more concerned
if nobody saw it but you know what
people did was it a ton of them no but
at the same time a lot of the past
Disney - the enemy of films didn't have
a ton of people looking at them and
nobody stream racism at that but I don't
know all the people in the world so it's
anybody's guess it's just a theory on
the whole though I really enjoy this one
I felt just like I was seeing little
mermaid or Beauty and the Beast again it
was great to see it on the big screen it
was great to see these characters and I
had a lot of fun watching it the
animations great the colors are great
the characters are great I enjoyed
watching it and I know I'll be seeing it
a few more times in the future
[Music]
this is the other animated Disney flick
that I'm sort of gonna cheat on tangled
I know technically it's a 3d animated
movie but let's be honest it's a 2d film
in 3ds clothing characters are designed
like 2d animation the backgrounds look
like something out of 2d animation the
story is very reminiscent of the
traditional Disney fairy tales it's
basically a 2d animated flick so I'll
bend the rules a little bit and review
this one as well and I also feel it a
little bit necessary to compare it to
the last 2d animated film The Princess
and the Frog I know that's probably not
fair to the movie but at the same time
one film only did okay and one film did
a lot better and this was the one that
did a lot better and seeing how they
came out back-to-back I guess it does
make sense to see why one did better
than the other so let's talk about the
absolute best aspect of the film the
story and it's rare that I say that but
the story to this film is brilliant this
is the classic retelling of a fairy tale
that Disney used to do best it's not
exactly like the original but the
changes are not only incredibly creative
but half the time they're improvements
it transitions the story into film
perfectly okay so what is it apparently
there's this magic flower that gives
eternal youth but it only seems to do it
when you sing a certain song that this
witch figured out so the witch has been
using the flower for years that is until
the queen of the land gets incredibly
sick so the flower is found and used to
keep her alive but the witch loses her
ability to keep young seems the flower
has been crushed down to herbs and has
now been passed on to the Queen's
daughter Republic flower power actually
seems to be in her hair so the witch
kidnaps Rapunzel when she's just a baby
and uses the power of her hair to grow
younger and seeing how she wants to live
longer and longer she grows the hair
longer and longer all throughout this
introduction I was shouting brilliant
brilliant brilliant this is a fantastic
setup there's a reason for the hair to
grow long there's no reason for her to
be in a tower there's a reason to
incorporate music into this it was
wonderful and on top of that the setup
for the rest of the story is actually
pretty good too
Rapunzel grows up into a teenager of
course under the care of her controlling
which mother but when a famous thief
enters her tower she knocks him out and
tries to get some information out of it
he agrees that if she lets him go he'll
lead her to this ceremony that seems to
take place every year on her birthday
this ceremony it turns out is raising a
bunch of lanterns in the hope that
someday she will find it and return back
home she agrees and from here on in it's
pretty much the adventure you think it'd
be their sword fighting horse riding
dancing singing romances evildoers all
the stuff you'd expect from Disney so
just from that ingenious set up you'd
expect this to be maybe one of the top
five Disney films of all time right well
there are some problems one is the voice
acting don't get me wrong it's not
terrible it's not even that bad I just
can't find myself getting bad invested
in these voices as soon as I heard
Rapunzel's voice and remember thing to
myself oh that's a celebrity voice and
would you know it it was and as soon as
I heard that these voice I remember
thinking hey that sounds like a guy
trying to do a thief's voice but not
actually a thief and that's my major
problem with this movie as brilliant as
the set up is everything feels like
they're trying to convey that
traditional Disney film sometimes it
works but other times
much like hunchback it feels pretty
forced like the musical segments they
just sort of come out of nowhere they
feel very rushed and I don't feel like
it really matches the movie I mean
granted a knob big fan of Randy Newman
but it matched in the princess of the
Frog it was Nora leads it made sense to
have that kind of music here this sort
of pop guitar slash Broadway slash
billboards hits sound I don't know it
seems a little out of place and honestly
those two things are my only problem but
they're kind of a big problem princess
and the frog it was the story and
everything else is fine
this the story is great but everything
else seems kind of done now don't get me
wrong there are some real standout
moments in fact I'll tell you my two
favorites one is the horse this is one
of the great movie horses he's like the
Javert of horses it's just a gray
character I could watch this thing
forever he just cracks me up the other
is the animation on the
parents now that's really interesting
because they never have a line in this
movie but holy smokes look at the
reaction on their faces look out torn
apart they are that is some of the best
emotion I've ever seen in any animation
and it's all done without words but
still that doesn't make up for the two
main characters and as I said before
they're not bad they're well-written and
they look great I honestly just think
it's the voice work and even then it's
not horrible I'm just always aware I'm
hearing somebody behind the microphone
I'm always hearing somebody acting I'm
always hearing somebody put out a
performance and when you're constantly
hearing that you can't get as invested
so why did this film do a lot better as
opposed to the last film about a
princess and The Princess and the Frog
is it a race issue it could be is it
because there's more guitar playing pop
songs that can appeal to the general
public more than ragtime - or lean sound
it's possible - but again I think it
comes back to my original theory 3d
animation I think the film did well
because the advertising played up that
there's gonna be more adult jokes even
though there weren't that many the fact
that the story to its credit was a lot
more simpler than princess in the frog
and like I said the fact that this 3d
animation makes adults think that it's
gonna be made for them - so do I like it
sure it's a good flick well the voice
acting is distracting it doesn't destroy
the film I mean I'm with it enough the
background still look nice there's a few
genuine soft moments the side characters
are fun and like I said it's a great
story I guess for me I just like the
updates to the Disney formula in The
Princess and the Frog more than I like
the updates in tank somewhere there's a
brilliant Disney movie here if we took
the story of tangled and the animation
and characters of Princess and the Frog
we could get something as brilliant as
Beauty and the Beast it's in there I
know it but still if you're looking for
a good adventure that also has that
fairy tale edge to it tangles not a bad
rent check it out and see what you can
get wrapped up
[Music]
and now we come to the last animated
film in Disney cember Winnie the Pooh
wait didn't we already do bunny the food
oh wait no that was the Adventures of
Winnie the Pooh this is just Winnie the
Pooh like what this is a biography or
something or is it a reboot like a
retelling of the original movie no there
are new stories that guess is just sort
of continuing it but why don't they call
it more adventures have we the board the
continuing Adventures of Winnie the Pooh
or give it a different title like they
did the other one in the blue movies I
don't know it's here let's reviewing all
your favorite characters are back
including Winnie piglet owl Tigger the
whole bunch and much like the original
film it doesn't seem like there's one
coherent story throughout the whole
thing well kind of sort of not really
yes I don't know okay let me explain who
is looking for a honey big shock and in
the meantime he finds out that ye'are
has lost his tail who tells everybody
about it and so everybody tries to get a
replacement tail but none of them really
seemed to work so they sort of leave
that story for a bit and they go on to
another story who tries to approach
Christopher Robin but he miss reads a
note and thinks that he's been kidnapped
by a monster called the Basset I won't
dare tell you as how they came to this
conclusion because to be very honest
it's very very funny so most of the
movie is trying to figure out how to
capture this muster called the Backson
and that's really about it those are the
only two stories in this movie I mean
it's done well I guess but why do we
spend so much time on just those two
stories the original had like a ton of
stories and that was awesome heck even
if you wanted to keep it to just one
story that'd be fine too but the scene
very split apart and even the way the
movie is told it seems like it's trying
to recreate what the first film was
doing you know a lot of fourth wall
jokes with the narrator and just sort of
taking time to let the
characters talk and breathe and just at
moments but we'll make that one work if
that it had a lot of stories this one
only has two that's very odd when the
film ended I was shocked I was like
really that's it
where's the rest of it there's got to be
more stories you can tell them that but
to be fair they're told pretty well as I
said before the film does recreate sort
of that feel that the first movie did
though just like I said too few stories
but it still has a pretty good
atmosphere and ease to it John Cleese's
the narrator and he's absolutely perfect
he's both dignified but can also sort of
give that sense of humor that the
original memory had - that's great
Ferguson as the owl and he's a little
different from the original character
he's a little bit more obsessed a little
bit more full of himself I mean the
original owl was kind of egotistical -
but this one seems obsessed with being
right
which I guess works okay but I don't
know was it rabid already sort of that
character wasn't he kind of the stick in
the mud or whatever I don't know it
works okay the songs are really friggin
good songs I guess it was done by the
same people who did Avenue Q and Book of
Mormon in fact one of the writers is
actually the voice of kanga that's
pretty cool they're so good that I
actually thought maybe it was the
Sherman Brothers I thought they came
back to do the music for this movie but
nope it's just the exact same spirit and
the exact same talent I guess if I had
to point out one other nitpick it would
be surprisingly the animation is a
little too good I know I know I'm never
satisfied but when you look at the
original Winnie the Pooh it's just the
perfect amount it's good animation but
still a little sketchy here the
backgrounds are still sketchy and they
look fine but the characters may be just
a little too clean and on top of that
they serve get Christopher Robin more
human-like eyes and oddly enough I saw
you like the da dies which I rarely do
but I think because everybody else has
them it's sort of worked and when you
suddenly see a character that has those
big Disney like eyes it sort of takes
you out of it a bit so not much and
again it's a nitpick I'm just trying to
the film is good it has a lot of funny
scenes the characters are still
wonderful it has some great songs the
biggest problem there is is that there
are only two stories and I still don't
get that why did they do a ton of
stories especially when it's called
Winnie the Pooh I mean you can recreate
this you're gonna have so much fun and
we stick it to two stories to be fair
though they're good stories along with
good characters good songs and
everything else in it it's not a great
flick but it's a good one if you're a
fan of Winnie the Pooh especially the
original I'd say go ahead and check it
out and folks that was Disney Semper
thank you so much for joining me in
looking over some of the most classic
and memorable of Disney animated movies
I'm sure you got your own opinions on
these movies so get out there share them
and hear what other people have to say
thanks so much for joining me and take
care
[Music]
by popular demand a goofy movie this is
a film I actually already talked about a
bit I could a list of the top nostalgic
critics I wouldn't review and one of
them was a goofy movie I wasn't really
sure why so many people wanted me to
review this I will say that in a sense I
was the exact wrong age to see this when
it came out I think it was just starting
to enter high school when you're
starting to enter high school you don't
want to see a Disney villain movie in it
so keep in mind I didn't grow up with
this I actually saw heroes later but for
what I saw I mean okay it's not among
one of the best Disney films or anything
but you know what for what I've got I
was actually kind of pleasantly
surprised the story is max now played by
a different voice actor it's forced to
go on a field trip with his father goofy
the only downside is all his friends are
going to a concert and even a possible
girlfriend named Roxanne might be there
as well so while on the trip he's
constantly trying to find a way to steer
the car towards the concert instead of
on the fishing trip that his father
wants to go on so yeah kind of a
standard story but what really sets it
apart oddly enough is the connection
between the father and the son the
father just wants to be a part of his
son's life and the son of course wants
his independence this could easily be
shown through a bunch of throwaway lines
and yeah they're in there too but
actually there's a lot of quiet and dare
even say it kind of mature moments in
this movie I mean it never goes too far
it always comes back to the fact that
it's a funny cartoon but for example
look at this opening artistically this
is a very nicely laid out movie and I
mean think about it you're doing
gooftroop the movie would you expect any
of this to be in it in fact it's
actually kind of cool to see Disney and
it made some modern day technologies
like what's the last time you saw a hot
tub in a Disney film and really they
don't take their gloves off even when
they go swimming Trenton's a weird I
will say one of the downsides is that
there's very little of Pete's family
that was always my favorite part of the
show we don't even see the wife the
crazy daughter and the dog and I really
missed that they were fogging
to be fair that's not the movies focused
it really is supposed to be about the
father and son and they keep it where it
should be as long as I don't remember
too well with the exception of the
opening one I have to man it is pretty
catchy
[Music]
the song done by the pop star at the
concert is also pretty enjoyable but
mostly for awkward coordinates it seems
like this and even a play down Pauly
Shore I actually work okay in the movie
in the same way that Zack Morris works
and Saved by the Bell
yeah you know it's not really popular
but you know what you give it a pass
it's cute it's energized the characters
are having a lot of 4-minute the romance
actually isn't that bad either
the Roxane character is actually kind of
cute and likable and the two of them
actually do share a believable chemistry
well I don't know has the shy stuttering
guy in the corner really ever gotten the
hot girl no it has but a goofy movie is
a very funny
it's Brandon colorful it's got good
stuff for kids and it's got a couple of
good things for adults as well
but jokes are pretty clever the
characters are pretty likable is no
masterpiece but I think it's definitely
workable
[Music]
by popular demand let's talk about
dinosaur this is the one for whatever
reason everybody has been pleading for
me to do even though it technically
isn't a 2d animated film my guess was
that the film must be so good that
obviously everybody wants me to review
it um okay I didn't quite see it as that
but alright let's start from the
beginning and I mean really from the
beginning let's go to the trailer
because this is the first thing a lot of
people saw the trailer was just the
first five minutes of the movie with a
little dinosaur egg being picked up and
traveling across fields of real-life
landscape and computer-generated
dinosaurs and I gotta admit it was
pretty cool it got a lot of us really
hyped up but then when a lot of people
saw the movie their reaction was kind of
similar ah they talked damn it I thought
they were really gonna do something new
with like the animals that don't talks
are like in Fantasia or do this really
adult story but okay oh well you know
what maybe you'll be like Leia before
time you know where it's this really big
story and really touching characters and
just this timeless but you need a little
help from
love monkey huh come on hot stuff let's
get going okay which celebrity is in the
Hat girls I'm known as the professor of
love
professor really they had professors in
the dinosaur age yeah I know I'm
probably over reading it but for God's
sakes look at this opening look at how
real they try to make these dinosaurs
they're obviously trying to tell this
really really big story and I'm sorry
you can't do it with these voices and
these references if it was something
like out of a Rudyard Kipling novel
maybe but I'll stop saying that
the story you've heard it a million
times it's Moses again a young one is
driven from his family to be raised by
somebody else
years later he grows up but find
something threatens his kind in this
case a meteorite so he finally comes
across his people and wouldn't you know
it
he emerges a leader again I'm willing to
put up with this if they give us
something new but these characters are
so bland and so tired the minute you see
the main character you know what he's
gonna be he's gonna be naive but
determined a wisecracker but knows when
to be serious the all-around good role
model who cracks a few jokes every now
and then what about the supporting
characters yeah the female love interest
who is just there to be the female love
interest yeah they talked twice and all
the sudden they're like laying eggs at
the end when did that happen
the jerky leader is the jerky leader oh
wait actually we have two jerky leaders
so that way we can do both story arts
the one with the guy who realizes his
mistakes and the one with a stubborn
jerk who never catches on love great you
gave us two cliches for one you got that
weird
I never get where some of the dinosaurs
talk but some don't you could argue
maybe they're not as intelligent but
look one of them's like a dog I'm sorry
that's really weird if it was like a
different animal maybe but when all the
rest of the dinosaurs can talk this is
really kind of odd it's like talking to
a person and then another person is
suddenly licking it scratching at you
it's I don't know just odd even all that
beautiful landscape we were promised in
the trail where most of its just traded
in for bland boring looking desert and I
know what they're getting across they're
supposed to be suffering the meteor hit
it's supposed to be bad times but when
your story and your characters are as
bland as this the least you can do is
give us something interesting to look at
now to the movies credit despite the
fact that the story's been done a
million times and these characters
haven't done a million times it's not
bad there's a few things I like for
example I really like these two older
dinosaurs they're constantly bringing up
the rear
they know they're slowing people down
but at the same time they're trying
their best to be optimistic and
hopefully the supportive mother though
again down a million times it's actually
a genuinely likeable character - I do
sort of like it when the one leader
realizes his mistake and is even ready
to die for it before a story like this
were obviously they're trying to tell a
great big tale with great big characters
nothing much really stands out about it
something like Land Before Time really
works because not only is it done with
Dinosaurs but still with the young
dinosaur and they don't use terms like
the love monkey they use terms that are
a little bit more timeless and you feel
the pain and the struggle they have to
get through because they're much younger
that makes the danger so much more grave
and they all have unique personalities
and you could easily gravitate towards
them you could get angry at them where
you could get sad for them and you can
get happy for them why is it I always
praise this movie whenever I'm talking
about Disney films so yeah I give the
film didn't do phenomenally well at the
box office you can probably see why but
again a lot of people really want me to
do this so I guess a lot of people out
there probably really enjoy it if you do
that's awesome like I said I don't think
there's anything ethically wrong or
really insulting about it it just seems
like a really been done story as well as
really been done characters and I know
that there's about five original stories
that we're all doing variations on and
like ten original characters that were
only doing variations on
the more they can hide it or at least
bring something new to the table that's
what makes a difference
and for me I just didn't feel this broad
enough and hated I just couldn't get
into it but hey apparently a lot of
people did and I'm sure a lot of people
still do if you're interested to see
what some people are talking about give
it a watch but if the same things that
annoy me also annoy you you probably say
give it us
[Music]
my popular demand Who Framed Roger
Rabbit a lot of people that asking me to
do this film and I guess I can sorta see
why it is technically Disney animation
even though it's mixed with live-action
it had groundbreaking technology and it
was the first time you saw characters
like Mickey Mouse and Bugs Bunny
together that's still so surreal to me
I'll spill the story real quick for all
what two of you that don't know it Eddie
valiant played by Bob Hoskins is a
detective in Hollywood apparently a very
wealthy prankster named Marvin Acme has
been murdered by a toon
Eddie doesn't mind too much see how he
has this incredible prejudice against to
it why because a toon killed his brother
how dropped the piano on his head that
is hilariously tragic everybody thinks
Roger Rabbit is to blame and so he goes
to Eddie valiant to try and salt the
case despite his prejudice he does
believe that the rabbit is innocent and
so with the help of the characters from
toontown including Rogers saucy hot wife
named Jessica they set out to solve the
mystery I'm trying to think what I can
say about this film that everybody else
hasn't already everybody's seen it
everybody wants it in fact they more
than loved it they go crazy for it so
okay let's talk about why people go
crazy for this film cuz to be honest I
never quite understood I mean don't get
me wrong I go crazy for it too I am in
love with this movie but I mean
everybody in the world seems to like
this film even the biggest sour pusses
is it the story yes but I don't know
it's not really much of a mystery I mean
take a guess who the bad guy is no
really come on take a wild guess
is it the characters well yeah they're
pretty good too but again nothing really
groundbreaking Wheesung characters with
prejudices before and they go through a
story arc that changes them back is it
how technically groundbreaking it is I
suppose but there's a lot of
technological groundbreaking movies that
people don't go gaga for like they do
with this movie even the idea of live
action actors interacting with cartoons
is not a new idea it's been done almost
since the beginning of animation so
really what
the secret formula that everybody can
identify with well I thought about why I
like the movie I mean sure the story and
characters are great but what is it I
love about it now that I love just as
much as when I was a kid and then it hit
me
this is the movie I always wanted to see
as a kid the films very clever and not
taking modern-day cartoons but rather
the timeless cartoons that everybody
grew up with they are the characters
that fill up the screen and like I said
before it's not just Disney characters
it's Warner Brothers characters
paramount characters it runs the gamut
and I can guarantee you everybody that
has ever grown up watching cartoons as
envision this imagining a film or a
story where every single one of their
favorite cartoon characters come
together and that's what this movie did
it brought everybody's childhood fantasy
to life it made these cartoon characters
that we grew up with read it treated
them with the same dedication and love
that we felt every single time we watch
them you don't see a modern-day
manipulation of Bugs Bunny
you see Bugs Bunny you don't see a
writer trying to recreate Mickey Mouse
you see Mickey Mouse and because it was
set in the past everybody knows these
characters and absolutely loved them and
because of the technology they have they
seem more real than ever and a good
story
some scary moments funny moments
dramatic moments romantic moments top it
off with some great writers and a good
director who put all their time and
energy into making these characters seem
just as real alive and believable to us
now as they were when we were children
and you have a movie that captures all
the zany does all the goofiness and all
the joy that we felt as children
watching these cartoons quite honestly
it's a perfectly written love letter to
our childhoods
you
[Music]